cabinet meeting discussing the
withdrawal agreement estimate VAE the
Work and Pensions Secretary has resigned
an hour or so earlier the brexit
secretary Dominic Rob also resigned from
the cabinet well let's get some
ministerial views on that with me now is
mr. Walker who is a briggsie Minister
you've lost your boss don't let go he's
someone I respect greatly personally but
obviously he took his personal views on
this and decided that he couldn't carry
on in that role I think the majority of
the party the majority of country will
want to see us deliver on brentd and
won't see us delivering it in a way that
allows us to continue to thrive
economically people will look at what's
going on today two ministers who sat in
that cabinet meeting yes there was only
and they'll say this is a government to
go below I think the Prime Minister was
clear but there was robust discussion in
the cabinet having spoken to Dominic
both in advance of the cabinet and
afterwards I'm clear that he made his
views very clearly known but I think it
is right but the Prime Minister has to
decide in the national interest that she
has to consult her cabinet in the
national interest and that cabinet
agreed with her but this was a deal to
go ahead with the deal but delivers on
taking control of our laws our borders
and our money but also does so in a way
that preserves the best interests of our
economy and the jobs in all of our
constituencies I mean we've already
heard from Chopra Munda this morning and
he'd say well look it's a bit rich here
we've got the people who thought brexit
was a good idea spent two years
negotiating it and now resigning in
protest of what they reserve and they
negotiated well I think chuckers
position is a bit rich frankly as
someone who is elected on the manifesto
to respect the outcome of the referendum
he's now campaigning directly against
that I think what we have to ensure is
that we deliver on the outcome of the
referendum but we do they do it in a way
that brings people together wherever
they supported leave or whether they
support it or me I think that's where
the vast majority of people in the car
okay now that the big issue and Anu
obviously the president Minister have a
chance to look at these 500 pages the
big issue is the Prime Minister's claim
that this deal is in the national
interest what why is it in the wrestling
it's in the national interest because
first and foremost it delivers on the
biggest democratic exercise we've had in
the history of this country this is a
referendum on leaving the European Union
secondly it secures the frictionless
trade but we have put the heart of our
negotiating position to ensure that
British businesses can continue to
thrive and provide jobs thirdly it
delivers the independent trade policy
which break sisters have always
campaigned for and which will give us
new opportunities in the world and
fourthly and crucially it keeps our
United Kingdom together the EU wanted to
put forward proposals which would have
divided the Northern Ireland often the
rest of the United Kingdom we've
rejected those and actually the outcome
of this deal is one but keeps the United
Kingdom recent intact mr. Robin his
resignation letter he says that's not
true he says that we could only get out
of the so-called backstop if the EU
agrees to that so that therefore we are
tied or Northern Ireland will be tied to
the EU indefinitely
the EU would love us to have been in a
situation where only they had a say of
course we would prefer to be in a
situation where we only we had a say
where we have reached a deal is
something which gives both parties an
equal say in the process I think that's
reasonable I think it's very clear but
the backstop arrangements are
uncomfortable for both parties it's not
something that the EU will want to be in
place for a long time because they would
see it is some form of cherry-picking of
under undermining the four freedoms from
our perspective we would much rather
have a future economic partnership which
delivers for the whole of the United
Kingdom and that's what we're focused on
achieving
I think in reality the backstop need not
come into force at all we need both
parties now to move forward on the
ambitious future declaration we set out
with regard to a relationship between us
and that is one but has the support of
the vast majority of businesses and
investors in this country it does look
as if you're Tory colleagues passed mr.
Raum is one of them
consequence of not supporting the Prime
Minister's deal is No Deal and a No Deal
breaks it what do you believe the
consequences would be if that's where we
end up well I think it's very clear that
providing the council gives its approval
to this deal we will have a vote in
parliament in a few week time and that
will be a choice between Medill villas
on offer with all the opportunities that
that offers in terms of an independent
trade policy in terms of the upside of
securing a long term access to the
European market as well versus a No Deal
situation and could Britain manage in a
No Deal I'm sure we could but it would
be very disruptive it would be very
difficult and that a short-term cost to
my constituents and people all over the
country but not
I want to see I want to see us deliver
for all our constituents across the UK
and I think every MP will have to think
very carefully with the deal that's
supported by both the UK government and
the European Union but this is a deal
that we can achieve which delivers
prosperity for all of us whether they
back that or not departments that did
raise some eyebrows last night by saying
that one possibility was what she called
no breaks it at all I mean are we
getting to that point where we call it
all I think what is very clear is that
there are some people out there
including even kissed armor of a shadow
vector secretary who are now talking
about that possibility we don't want to
see that I I promised my constituents I
would deliver on the outcome of the
referendum and I think it's vital that
we do I think what we have here is a
deal that allows us to do that while
safeguarding the economic interest of
our country and that's something that I
think all right-thinking thinking people
should get behind now finally are you
expecting that there will be a vote of
confidence in the Prime Minister I'm not
making predictions today what I do think
though is that the Prime Minister has
the support of the vast majority of
people in our party and she has the
support of people across the country in
delivering the right outcome which is
delivering on the referendum but doing
it in a way that meets the needs of area
so if if there was a vote of confidence
she'd win it presumably I think she
would but I don't think I'm not
speculating about that I think I think
she has the support of colleagues across
the party I was in a briefing last night
with backbenchers from across the party
who were applauding the deal but it's
been structured okay Robbie Walker that
Britain Minister very busy day for him
thickly as he hasn't got Secretary of
State on his department from now let's
speak to Kate McCarran our political
correspondent she's in Downing Street
Kate McCarrick comings and goings to
cabinet resignations now estimate very
and Dominic Rob can we expect more well
that's right to cabinet resignations
another ministerial resignation and I
wouldn't put want to put any money on
the not being any more resignations
today in fact if you think about it
they're coming roughly every hour and if
I were cynical I might say that that
were coordinated but s in mcveigh's
resignation letter to the Prime Minister
is incredibly strong she says here the
deal you put before the cabinet
yesterday does not honor the results of
the referendum indeed it doesn't meet
the tests you set from the outset of
your Premiership but here is the key
point she is another Minister today
another resignation to say that the deal
that syriza may have struck with
Brussels is a threat to the Union
now that's a really important phrase
because that's something that Ruth
Davidson the leader of the Conservative
Party in Scotland and David Mandel the
Scottish secretary have also been quite
concerned about now if we were thinking
about people who might be forced to
resign in the coming in the coming days
or even in the coming hours at the
moment they could pre people to watch
because if there are three ministers now
resigning on that basis that makes their
position incredibly difficult our
estimate way of course was the minister
in charge of the Universal Credit
program she was there was a lot of
controversy around her at the time of
that she also had some fairly
significant concerns about brexit and as
we were hearing before Dominic Rob and
Aston McVeigh made those concerns clear
to to resume in that cabinet meeting
yesterday it looks like they feel now
that they are unable to continue in
their positions because the Prime
Minister has said that she will forge
ahead with this agreement and try and
push it through the House of Commons I
mean there is an argument being made
here that these Euroskeptics
who are resigning are maximizing their
pressure now but that perhaps are the
process is now inexorable towards a vote
in Parliament where really the choice is
going to be between No Deal or this deal
well that's right I was just speaking to
a senior government minister he was
saying that now No Deal looks much more
likely than it ever has done before and
that's because a load of complex reasons
about trying to get this vote through
the House of Commons there really isn't
an alternative option here it's the
reason may will present the agreement
that she has reached with Brussels but
after that there isn't another
alternative lots of people would like to
see a second referendum lots of Labour
MPs would like to see that happen
there's not a clear not a clear
mechanism for that coming through the
House of Commons
so these resignations make no deal more
likely now apparently according to my
sources this was discussed in cabinet
yesterday there were calls from cabinet
ministers for syriza made to step up
that no deal planning they want to see
more border guards they want to see more
money being put into things like customs
arrangements at the border because they
feel and there is a real concern now
that no deal could be more likely now
this is something that has pushed other
cabinet ministers to warn that everybody
needs to stay united they need to stay
behind the Prime Minister because of
course there is a lot of concern about
what No Deal would mean for the country
and while we're all talking in
Westminster here about what ministers
think what Cabinet ministers
think don't forget to resume is also
presenting her plan today to businesses
and that will be a key point because
business is very very concerned indeed
about a No Deal just one more thing
worth mentioning another one of those
cabinet ministers that is said to be
thinking about considering her position
is penny mordant now she is the
international development secretary she
is currently in the House of Commons
taking questions from MPs I understand
that she is looking closely at her phone
and just one thing Kate as well doing
any of them actually say at this cabinet
meeting yesterday that they were going
to resign that's the million dollar
question we don't know of course because
we weren't in the cabinet meeting and we
don't get a full readout but from
speaking to people who were there a lot
of cabinet ministers made their views
very clear to the Prime Minister now it
sounds as if they didn't go as far as to
say that they were going to resign over
this agreement but they left her in no
doubts that there were some serious
issues with that Northern Irish board a
problem with this customs union
arrangement and whether that would be
time limited obviously now we know there
won't be a unilateral mechanism for the
UK to withdraw from that that sparked
Dominic Suarez Dominic Grubbs
resignation but even number 10 last
night was saying that there were
uncomfortable conversations going on in
cabinet that the tone of discussion was
impassioned they were making no secret
of the fact that cabinet ministers had
made their case quite clearly they had
expressed their opinions they'd express
their concerns to the Prime Minister but
overall in the end of course because
there isn't a show of hands at cabinet
meetings there isn't a vote even though
sources say estimate they did ask the
prime minister for one particularly on
this really important issue there isn't
about the Prime Minister got collective
agreement for her plan and so it now
precedes to the next stage okay thank
you very much indeed caper can there
well let's get the thoughts now of Lord
hain of course former labor cabinet
minister and Northern Ireland secretary
he's with us also here at beth Rigby our
deputy political editor now Lord hain
Dominic Rob's complaints is centered
around this text of the Irish backstop
and he's basically saying that we're
giving part of Northern Ireland to the
you in terms of the EU are being able to
decide his future well there never was a
solution to the Irish border if you
adopted the kind of pole position that
the Conservative government has adopted
what you need to have to maintain the
Irish border is completely open as it
has been very successfully now for quite
a long time is both sides of it in the
same single market and the same the
customs union whatever you call that and
this was not possible given the
government's stance that it didn't want
to do that so it's not surprising that
this has fallen over on that point so
what do you like about the textile long
island well I don't think it resolves
the problem it postpones the problem
it's a fudge it gets you through the
next stage and it could keep as it were
edging the fudge further down the line
if if it were extended beyond October
2020 but it doesn't deal with a
fundamental problem nor does the whole
deal I mean we were told in the leave
campaign in 2016 that you'd get more
control actually you're getting less
control under this deal the tourism a
wants Parliament to adopt because the
Council of Ministers will no longer have
a British representative nor will the
Parliament so we'll actually be taking
rules from Brussels having less control
I do not accept and tourism a wants us
to be presented with this one or the
other either this deal her deal or no
deal there is an alternative there is an
alternative of Parliament to say we
don't like either of these options a new
deal would be catastrophic if a
parliament could say what it's like to
is blue in the face there's another side
to these negotiations which is the
indeed but the European Union if it were
presented with a sensible agenda from
Parliament taking control really taking
back control for as representatives of
the people then I think the European
Union would bite our hands off to get a
decent deal that works for Europe and it
works for us and what would that deal be
well I think it's going to be staying in
the single market than the customs union
and actually nothing is better than
where we are now marking the customs
union we're not taking back control we
still got freedom invisible about where
as I was about to say why it is not far
better to be where we are now
in the European year
to give people the chance to say yes we
voted to give Brussels our kicking and
give the political elite a pick a
kicking and I felt that on the doorstep
hundreds of doors I knocked on in 2060
than the referendum people were angry
but they didn't want to be worse off and
I think they're now faced with this
choice actually should be given a say
you're clearly not a referendum I'm
voting I'm campaigning for a people's
votes on the farm the question is the
question is their choice the choice is
this Deal or No Deal or actually staying
in the European the three options three
option how do you decide a referendum
with three options people have worked on
this and it's quite clear how you decide
you vote for what you choose yeah and so
33 percent vote for each or 34 percent
for one 32% for another 30 well the
mechanics of this are very clear on a
lot of issues well this is how a lot of
votes happen already and you know people
should be given a choice is this really
what we want is to unite the country we
know the country is divided down the
middle of it
exactly and dividing everyone the reason
is we are in the mess we are is tourism
a has not adopted a one nation approach
to this she's adopted a position to try
and keep the Jacob Riis mugs and her
hardliners including the cabinet
ministers that are so far resigned in
play she's not managed even to do that
that is why and we need a completely
fresh approach to this and I think in
the end you cannot get out of this this
was a process started by a referendum it
has to be in there's not the process the
current Labour leadership are advocating
there is it well party conference left
open the option other people's votes
Kirsten has made that very clear as of
others in the leadership that was the
party's policy our party leaders always
said he respects conference policy and I
would expect him to continue to do that
okay Peter Haim thank very much well
we're monitoring what's going on in
Downing Street Julian Smith the Chief
Whip just left there I think we're now
thinking that the key vote is going to
be in December December the 14th wasn't
it all yeah they want to try and do it
before December I've just actually had a
text from minister in the chamber and I
said that trees maze just apparently
gone in looking rather drained actually
she's gone which I don't know well she
must have left her mother must have left
by the back door maybe now what do you
make of resignation well well are we
look had last night when she came out
she got her first version of events out
which was it was difficult I've done
this in the national interest I have
collective cabinets appalled what she
didn't say was actually ten people spoke
up against me and I got it over the line
but there was a lot of unhappiness in
the room and now we've seen the fallout
of that aren't we I had three people on
my resignation watchlist last night but
this was from what cabinet sources had
told me number one was estimate Vey she
has just gone number two was penny Moore
who's answering questions in the machine
of the machine but with her resignation
letter out on Twitter
number two was penny Malden and number
three was Borden is going yes well penny
Morden is I think on the brink she's on
the edge she's weighing it up as I
understand it a cabinet last yesterday
she made this case for a free vote in
parliament she said that was the only
way the Prime Minister could protect the
stability of government - ie don't try
and force your party to a place they
can't go don't try and force me took
place I can't either
and I think sorry I don't but I think
what she's going to try and do is she's
gonna see what the Prime Minister says
in her statement
now if the Prime Minister offers a free
vote which apparently lots of brexit
ears Warren and junior ministers one it
might buy the PM some breathing space
but Morden will might be making a
calculation as you know as all of them
are which is if I want to run for the
next prime minister or to run to lead
the Conservative Party do I want to be
the brexit ear that has supported and
stayed in a government on a deal that my
colleagues just not stomach just said as
you saw I just stood thinking a Robin
Walker the minister let me put it to you
theory that perhaps we're getting a bit
overexcited of course it's very dramatic
when these people reside but frankly
Dominic Rob penny mordant estimate very
they don't have a great track record as
politicians or national leader
they're people who've been given an
opportunity to serve by the Prime
Minister rather than being essential
appointees to the cabinet if they go so
what if we've got cause we've got you
know the Chancellor there
the Home Secretary there the Foreign
Secretary there and all the others but
that's true to a point but the issue she
always had was that she had to get it
through cabinet to hold on to her
cabinet to the point that she could even
try and go into battle in Parliament and
we've all been saying for weeks haven't
we that it was pretty difficult maths as
it was and if she starts losing
ministers and cabinet ministers from
remain and leave sides it looks to me
like that deal is well and truly dead I
mean it was barely on life support and
now it's well and truly dead the big
question in that's what you're getting
to is does it actually end her
Premiership and there's division there
because some people will say of course
she can still survive a free vote the
majority of the party will staying
behind or what's the alternative but a
couple of people that walk past
okay excitable this morning has said
that they're struggling to see how she
can go on if these resignations carry on
okay let's get the thoughts of the
leader of the Liberal Democrats of
attending their MP thank you for joining
us what do you think and Mrs May
struggle on with this statement and
putting it before but it's pretty
disastrous I've been as you've said a
few minutes ago the government can
afford a few resignations but I think
Rob was some day they couldn't afford to
lose I mean he he's after the ball the
guy who negotiated this and these both
called Davis and then indeed I mean I
think the conclusion one has to reach is
that it's now not possible for this deal
to go through Parliament and we are now
in the territory of looking at other
options and much more radical options
including something the Prime Minister
hates but may be instructed by
Parliament to follow with just other
people's both
what do you think that she's forgetting
to entertain that possibly I doubt that
she is personally entertaining but she
may be told that there is no other of
course all right now there are
sub-cabinet resignation so Ella
Braverman of course was there it was a
leading men well now you remember when
David Davis resigned and then Steve
Baker resigned back over checkers there
were these frantic rumors overnight this
swel a brave man who had once been the
chair of the ERG brexit a group was
going to go and she I think her
colleagues on the Braxtons winged
decided that swellin needed to stay in
to give them a voice in government so
she's gone now so how many brexit
ministers remain in that offer
Department now is it just Robin Walker
one remain is still standing
still got we've still got um Chris heats
and Harris is still that as well the key
point I think once they start going once
it looks like a lost cause that all
those people have been hanging in the
government for career reasons we'll see
no point I'm in there but the people who
are going our heartbreaks the tears yes
and you know looking on you might be a
bit bewildered saying well this is
actually a negotiation and agreement to
leave the European Union but the people
in protesting against it the people who
want to leave the European Union well
indeed but in a bizarre way we now have
common ground between people like myself
and many of them because we've been
offered a prospect of a an arrangement
which is largely following the rules of
the European Union but I mean no sale
and I think but you are on the game of
chicken because you would like a
people's vote and the outcome of that to
be to stay they want a hard brexit which
they accept would have a disruptive
impact initially on the British economy
so you're making common cause destroying
a compromise and you might get the worst
option you might get a heart breaks it
and similarly the heart breaks the tears
might get the other people's very tight
for a hard wreck suit so-called crushing
out it's potentially so disastrous I
don't think there's but all these people
are resigning there
remotely like a majority of people in
Parliament for that has come out I'll
pull you back okay well mrs. May they're
just seeing pictures of her leaving
Downing Street so sources about her
looking pale and one in the chamber not
necessarily true yeah we've got we're
gonna look out for fake news for various
real news the Prime Minister now on her
way to the houses of parliament to give
a statement to the Commons another
resignation coming through who is it
anne-marie Trevelyan Amory terellian
another so that brings it to 5:00 this
morning right okay oh my tol right okay
we will have more news and probably more
resignations coming up in just a moment
stay with us
[Music]
at this West London Street market the
stalls have a weight problem customers
don't want to buy by the kilo so they
sell by the bowl do you have a mental
idea of what a kilo of apples looks like
to be honest life
so is it easier to buy the bowl I think
it's easy to buy the ball and now it
seems scientists aren't sure what a
kilogram looks like either this is their
best guess a lump of titanium so
precious is locked away and rarely taken
out of its protective container every
scale in Britain is calibrated against
it but the kilogram itself is the
cylinder of metal you can see clamped
it's called kilo 18 a copy of the mother
of all kilos another titanium cylinder
secured in Paris since 1889 the problem
is LeGrande K has lost atoms over the
years 20 billionth of a gram the weight
of an eyelash and it's cents science
into a spin when you get down to very
very small masses like a milligram then
you're dealing with active quantities in
drugs like constancy of aspirin you're
taking and uni also you need to get that
right and that needs to be traceable to
a very accurate standard then you move
the coil in the magnetic field at the
National Physical Laboratory scientists
are trying to come up with a more exact
definition using a high-tech set of
scales that measure the electromagnetic
force needed to balance a kilogram then
with some head-scratching maths turn
that into a number tied to the physical
laws of the universe an unchanging and
highly accurate definition of the
kilogram that can be used anywhere no
longer tied to a weight in Paris
you
well welcome back to all-out politics
the Prime Minister on her way to
Parliament to make her statement to the
Commons on the withdrawal agreement
reached with Europe and approved at
yesterday's cabinet meeting but
following that cabinet meeting already
this morning
there have been five ministerial
resignations two of them from the
cabinet itself Dominic rabe the brexit
secretaries resigned estimate vais has
resigned there are a lot of rumors about
penny more than the International
Development Secretary in junior
ministerial ranks Santosh vara has
resigned as well a bravoman has resigned
and also we understand Amory Trevelyan
four out of five of those strong
supporters of briggsie I'm going to get
the thoughts of the Labour MP Graham
stringer in just a moment but let's go
to our political editor part of Islam
who is in Downing Street
well Faisal what do you make of it so
far well I pretty surreal stuff and
we've just been inside Downing Street
for a no phone's briefing about the
detail of this 500 page deal and the
question posed by everybody at that is
is this a a moot point now going through
the details of what happens on the
Northern Irish border what happens to
frictionless trade in the car industry
Downing Street trying to sell this deal
at the very moment that cabinet
ministers were resigning junior
ministers were resigning letters flying
like the opening scene to Harry Potter
it is quite an extraordinary situation
frankly the Prime Minister who's just
left here to go over to Downing Street
penny modern I think is speaking right
now in the House of Commons I don't know
if we can we want to dip into that right
now
but we've just got the letter here from
swellow braverman pretty extraordinary
to think that you're in there with the
technicians who have crafted this deal
exhaustively with the European Union
and to see it immediately with ministers
involved in that department
basically derided by those ministers the
cabinet minister obviously Dominic Robb
the most high-profile that seems to have
started a domino effect of other
ministers going
various ranks and I don't think we've
seen the end of it so for the Prime
Minister deep drama and deep crisis they
knew that this was going to be a sticky
moment but sticky understates it by a
factor of hundreds the Prime Minister
will now have quite the job on her and I
think fighting for her deal fighting for
her job when she goes to the House of
Commons in just a few minutes files will
be back with you shortly let's get the
thoughts now officer Graham stringer
veteran Labour MP also one of those
breaks a tear Labour MPs who has helped
the prime minister and the provision
lobbies in the past
first of all just you know as an
observer what do you make of what's
happening these string of resignations
for them well I think he's falling apart
before our very eyes and send him a
can't survive as Prime Minister she's
failed in the negotiations she needs to
step aside for somebody else who can get
a better deal than this and better than
that would be a jungler lecture so the
electric could decide who they wanted to
negotiate I mean do you think we are
heading towards the general election I
think it's still less than 50% chance
but the the percentage chances is
increasing by the hour I think so you
are not inclined to secure brexit which
this with Rory whether you're not
inclined to say I could give the Prime
Minister my vote is no I I don't think
he does secure brexit it doesn't hit
most of the fundamental points about his
taking back control which puts the
country of his best Northern Ireland off
a knee costs a fortune
so I can't vote for that I mean what the
Prime Minister has done as unite the
Labour Party against this deal and
destroy her own own party on it I mean
she's proved that this deal is worse
than no deal well easy I mean yes I
think it is I I think to pay a fortune
when you don't get control of anything
and you give the EU a complete veto on
when you get out of a customs union that
is not implementing well the people
voted for in 2016 they voted very simply
today back control of our borders our
money and our laws and she is no
delivering so what do you think would
happen if this deal collapses and
therefore we drift towards leaving
without a deal in March what do you
think the consequences would be for your
constituents and others well I I think
in terms of trade that probably be a hit
on on trade but that huge amount of
money that she was going to pay over to
the EU could be used to fill more than
that gap I worth I've my constituency
coast pass of sulfur to Manchester that
would keep those two councils going not
the total amount just the amount 600
million per constituency for two years
without any council tax or government
grumps that's the extent of what she
wants to give away while not getting
control of our own laws but but I mean
are you saying that we said there would
there would be a hit economically I mean
that would presumably put more pressure
on public services because there'll be
less grows I think it would be a short
term the EU sign of the World Trade
Organization we would have to trade on
that basis the majority of our trade is
it is not with the US on World Trade
Organisation so the vast majority of it
what would continue the bounty is small
amount of disruption well we would then
be able to get back control of our own
laws so that we could make those laws
little fitted our own industry so there
would be an immediate benefit what about
the argument there if you don't like
this deal we'd be better off just stay I
think of that would be to undermine the
largest vote in our Democratic history I
think that would just be wrong and would
lead to a fundamental disbelief in
democracy by the general public saying
thank you very much indeed now skies as
Sarah had Ruby Gary has been speaking to
a very important man at this particular
moment the Chief Whip Julian Smith
we've got a deal and that's the most
important thing Prime Minister has done
a brilliant job in the negotiating team
got a November council hopefully and
we're moving things on and the Prime
Minister's moving things are in the best
interest of country for families for
jobs frictionless trade and delivering
on the commitment she's made and
respecting the referendum it's a very
very major decision that the cabinet
said yesterday not everybody's going to
agree with it
my friends the members for sure and
Wharton and tatran delivering brexit
involves difficult choices for all of us
we do not agree on all of those choices
but I respect their views and I would
like to thank them Cecile sincerely for
all that they have done mr. speaker
yesterday we agreed the professional
terms of our exit from the European
Union set out in the draft withdrawal
agreement we also agreed the broad terms
of our future relationship in an outline
political declaration president Younker
has now written to the president of the
European Council to recommend that
decisive progress has been made in the
negotiations and a special European
Council will be called for Sunday the
25th of November this puts as close to a
brexit deal mr. speaker what we agreed
yesterday was not the final deal it is a
draft treaty
[Applause]
it is a draft treaty that means that we
will leave the EU in a smooth and
orderly way on
and which sets the framework for a
future relationship that delivers in our
national interest it takes back control
of our borders laws and money it
protects it protects jobs security and
the integrity of the United Kingdom and
it delivers in ways that many said could
simply not be done we were told that we
had a binary choice between the model of
Norway or the model of Canada that we
could not have a bespoke deal but the
outline political declaration sets out
an arrangement that is better for our
country than both of these a more
ambitious free trade agreement than the
EU has with any other country and we
were told we will be treated like any
other third country on security
cooperation but the outline political
declaration sets out a breadth and depth
of cooperation beyond anything the EU
has agreed with any other country so let
me take the house through the details
first on the withdrawal agreement the
full legal text has now been agreed in
principle it sets out the terms on which
the UK will leave the EU in 134 days
time on the 29th of March 2019 we have
secured the rights of the more than 3
million EU citizens living in the UK and
around 1 million UK nationals living in
the U EU we have agreed a time-limited
implementation period that ensures
businesses only have to plan for one set
of changes we have agreed protocols to
ensure Gibraltar and the sovereign base
areas are covered by the withdrawal
agreement and we have agreed a fair
financial settlement far lower than the
figures many mentioned at the start of
this process mr. speaker since the start
of this process I have been committed to
ensuring that our exit from the EU deals
with the issue of the border between
Northern Ireland and Ireland I believe
this issue can best be solved through
our future relationship with the
European Union but the withdrawal
agreement sets out an insurance policy
should that new relationship not be
ready in time at the end of the
implantation period
I do not pretend that this has been a
comfortable process or all that either
we or the EU are entirely happy with all
of the arrangements that have been
included within it but of course this is
the case this is an arrangement that we
have both said we never want to have to
use but while some people might pretend
otherwise there is no deal which
delivers the brexit the British people
voted for which does not involve this
insurance policy not Canada plus plus
plus not Norway for now not our own
white paper the EU will not negotiate
any future partnership without it as the
house knows the original proposal from
the EU was not acceptable as it would
have meant creating a customs border
down the Irish Sea and breaking up the
integrity of our United Kingdom so last
month I set out for the house the four
steps we needed to take this is what we
have now done and it has seen the EU
make a number of concessions towards our
position first the EU proposal for a
Northern Ireland only custom solution
has been dropped and replaced by a new
UK wide temporary customs arrangement
that protects the integrity of our
precious union second we have created an
option for a single time limited
extension of the implementation period
as an alternative to bringing in the
backstop as I have said many times I do
not want to extend the implementation
period and I do not believe we will need
to do so this is about an insurance
policy but if it happens that at the end
of 2020 our future relationship is not
quite ready the UK will be able to make
a choice between the UK wide temporary
customs arrangement or short extension
of the imitation period third the
withdrawal agreement commits both
parties to use best endeavours to ensure
this insurance policy is never used and
in the unlikely event that it is needed
if we choose the backstop the withdrawal
agreement is explicit but it is
temporary and that the article 50 legal
base cannot provide for a permanent
relationship and there is also a
mechanism
by which the backstop can be terminated
finally we have ensured full continued
access for Northern Ireland's businesses
to the whole of the UK internal market
mr. speaker the brexit talks are about
acting in the national interest and that
means and that means making what I
believe to be the right choices not the
easy ones I know there are some who have
said I should simply rip up the UK's
commitment to a backstop but this would
have been an entirely irresponsible
course of action it would have meant
reneging on a promise made to the people
of Northern Ireland during the
referendum campaign and afterwards but
under no circumstances would brexit lead
to a return to the borders of the past
and it would have made it impossible to
deliver a withdrawal agreement as Prime
Minister of the United Kingdom I have a
responsibility to people in every part
of our country and I intend to honor
that promise
mr. speaker by resolving this issue we
are now able to move on to finalizing
the details of an ambitious future
partnership the outline political
declaration we have agreed sets out the
basis for these negotiations and we will
negotiate intensively ahead of the
European Council to turn this into a
full future framework the declaration
will end free movement once and for all
instead we will have our own new skills
based immigration system based not on
the country people come from but on what
they can contribute to the UK the
declaration agrees the creation of a
free trade area for goods with zero
tariffs no fees charges or quantitative
restrictions across all goods sectors no
other major advanced economy has such an
arrangement with the EU and at the same
time we will also be free to strike new
trade deals with other partners around
the world we have also reached common
ground on a close relationship on
services and investment including
financial services which go well beyond
WTO commitments the declaration ensures
we will be leaving the Common
Agricultural Policy and the Common
Fisheries Policy so we will decide how
best to sustain and support our farms
and our environment and the UK will
become an independent coastal state once
again we have also reached agreement on
key elements of our future security
partnership to keep our people safe this
includes swift and effective extradition
arrangements as well as arrangements for
effective data exchange on passenger
Name records DNA fingerprints and
vehicle registration data and we have
agreed a close and flexible partnership
on foreign security and defence policy
mr. speaker when I first became prime
minister in 2016 there was no ready-made
blueprint for brexit many people said it
could simply not be done I've never
accepted that by being committed day and
night to delivering on the result of the
referendum
and ensuring the u.k leaves the EU
absolutely and on time but I also said
at the very start but withdrawing from
EU membership after 40 years and
establishing a wholly new relationship
that would endure that will endure for
decades to come would be complex and
require hard work I know it's been a
frustrating process it has forced us to
confront some very difficult issues but
a gooda brexit a brexit which is in the
national interest is possible
we have persevered and have made a
decisive breakthrough once a final deal
is agreed I will bring it to Parliament
and I will ask MPs to consider the
national interest and give it their
backing voting
13 against a deal would take us all back
to square one it would mean more
uncertainty more division and a failure
to deliver on the decision of the
British people that we should leave the
EU if we get behind a deal we can bring
our country back together and seize the
opportunities that lie ahead
a mr. speaker the British people want us
to get this done and to get on with
addressing the other issues they care
about creating more good jobs in every
part of the UK doing more to help
families with the cost of living helping
our NHS to provide first-class care and
our schools to give every child a great
start in life and focusing every ounce
of our energy on building a brighter
future for our country so Mr Speaker the
choice is clear we can choose to leave
with no deal we can risk no brexit at
all or we can choose
[Applause]
or or we can choose to unite and support
the best deal that can be negotiated
this deal a deal the TENS free movement
takes back control of our borders laws
and money delivers a free trade area for
goods with zero tariffs leaves the
Common Agricultural Policy in the Common
Fisheries Policy delivers an independent
foreign and defense policy while
retaining the continued secure security
cooperation to keep our people safe
maintain shared commitments to high
standards protects jobs honors the
integrity of our United Kingdom and
delivers the brexit the British people
voted for I choose to deliver for the
British people I choose to do what is in
our national interest and I commend this
statement to the house
[Applause]
Thank You mr. speaker and I want to
thank the Prime Minister for an advanced
copy of her statements withdrawal
agreement and the outline political
declaration represent a huge and
damaging failure after two years of
bungled negotiations the government has
produced a botched deal that breaches
the Prime Minister's own red lines and
does not meet our six Tests
[Applause]
the government mr. speaker is in chaos
their deal risk leaving the country in
an indefinite halfway house without a
real say when even the last brexit
secretary who's theoretically at least
negotiated the deal says I cannot
support the proposed deal what faith
does that give anyone else in this place
or in this country the government simply
cannot put to Parliament this half-baked
deal that both the brexit secretary and
his predecessor have rejected No Deal is
not a real option and the government has
not seriously prepared for it the
government must publish its full legal
advice and the Treasury of full economic
impact assessment of the deal and the
obr an updated economic forecast the
withdrawal agreement is a leaf in the
dark an ill-defined deal by a never
defined date there is no mention of the
Prime Minister's favoured term
implementation period anywhere in the
585 pages of this document and no wonder
there is precious little new to
implement spelt out in either the
agreement or the political declaration
article 3 of the agreement states
transition can be extended to end by
31st of December 20 xx can the Prime
Minister confirm that this permits
extensions to be rolled on until 2099
can the Prime Minister confirm that if
the UK government cannot agree a
comprehensive future relationship by
January 2021 which few believe would be
possible and the last two years gives us
no confidence this government can then
those negotiations would have to be put
on hold because the focus would then
inevitably shift from negotiations on
the future relationship
to the negotiations on an extension of
the transition period including further
payments to the EU article 1 3 2 sets
out this process fairly clearly so can
the Prime Minister firstly tell the
house how confident she is that a deal
can be done by the end of 2020 and also
confirm that if a new trade agreement is
not agreed by the 31st December 2020
then article 1 3 2 applies paying a huge
financial contribution in order to
extend the transition period if we are
to avoid triggering the backstop as the
Prime Minister insists is her position
on the backstop itself should it come
into force there is no time limit or end
point and if either party requests a
review and if there is no agreement it
goes to independent arbitration the
backstop locks Britain into a deal from
which it cannot leave without the
agreement of the EU in the backstop
restrictions on state aid are hardwired
in with an arbitration mechanism but no
such guarantee exists for workers rights
can the Prime Minister also confirmed
that the backstop applies separate
regulatory rules to Northern Ireland
creating a de facto border down the
Irish Sea as Northern Ireland will be
subject to the customs union but not the
rest of the UK this is despite the fact
that the current prime minister said
this is something and I quote no new
crack UK Prime Minister could ever agree
to another of her red lines breached in
fact the list of EU measures that
continue to apply to the quotes of the
UK in respect of Northern Ireland runs
268 pages of the agreement this effects
v80 declarations and rules of origin
checks and it's clear the Prime
Minister's redline regarding the
jurisdiction of the European Court of
Justice has also been torn up by 2021
under the prior
ministers plan we will either be in a
backstop or still in transition we will
continue to contribute to the East
EU budget and follow the rules overseen
by the ECJ it is utterly far-fetched for
the Prime Minister's say this plan means
we take control over our laws money and
borders after two years of negotiation
all the government has really agreed is
a vague seven page outline of political
declarations which looks like a
substantial dilution of the Prime
Minister's previously declared
negotiating priorities there is only the
scan gist mention of workers rights
consumers rights or environmental
protection no determination to achieve
frictionless trade or even trade as
frictionless as possible no ambition to
negotiate a new customer comprehensive
customs union that would protect trade
jobs and Industry and so uncertainty
continues for business and all those
that work in those businesses that risks
decisions for investment being deferred
even further costing jobs and living
standards and many companies may decide
the lack of certainty simply means they
will brexit no clear plan to get a
strong deal with the single market to
ensure continued access to European
markets in services merely a vague
commitment to go beyond the baseline of
the World Trade Organization both the
First Minister's of Wales and Scotland
made clear to the Prime Minister that
participation in a customs union to
protect the economy and jobs was
essential likewise mr. speaker there is
no ambition to achieve continuation of
the European wide arrest warrant or an
equivalent and no clarity about our
status with Europol euro just or even
the Galileo project and there is no
clarity about any future immigration
system between the UK and the EU and
following the Windrush scandal many EU
nationals here will have no
confidence no confidence at all in this
government to deliver a fair and
efficient system the brexit secretary
promised a substantive document he's
obviously no longer here so can the
Prime Minister inform the house when
that detailed framework agreement will
be with us mr. speaker this is not the
deal the country was promised and
Parliament cannot and I believe will not
accept a false choice between this bad
deal and no deal people around the
country will be feeling anxious this
morning about the industries they work
in the jobs they hold about the
stability of their communities and their
country the government must now withdraw
this half-baked deal which is clear does
not have the backing of the cabinet this
Parliament or the country as a whole
[Applause]
Thank You mr. speaker now to pick up
some of the points that the right
honourable gentleman made first of all
he comments on he said that no deal was
not an option but then said complains
that we weren't preparing for no deal
actually our have been preparing for no
deal and we continue to prepare for no
deal because I recognize that obviously
we have a further stage of negotiation
with the European Council and then that
deal when the goat when finalized with
the European Council has to come back to
this house so we will continue those
preparations he says that the withdrawal
agreement is ill-defined 500 pages of
detailed legal text on the withdrawal
agreement is not an ill-defined
withdrawal agreement he complains he
complains that withdrawal agreement does
not refer to the implementation period
of course it does refer to the
transition period which is exactly the
same point of time he talks about he he
then talked about the whole question of
the decision on the backstop and the
implementation period I was coming at
the end of December 2020 well if he
looks
Gaynor the documents that have been
produced he will see that actually the
decision will be taken in June 2020 as
to whether it is likely that the future
relationship will not be put in place on
the 1st of January 2021 and a decision
at that point will be for the UK to
decide whether it wishes to extend the
implementation period for a limited
period or whether it wishes to go into
the backstop he is wrong in saying we
have been absolutely he is wrong he is
wrong in saying he is wrong in saying
that we will have not dealt with the
issue of the border down the Irish Sea
we have dealt with that I was clear in
this house that we would it took some
considerable time to persuade the
European Union to move from its proposal
for a Northern Ireland only customs
territory to any UK wide customs
territory but we have achieved achieved
that in relation to the question of
workers rights there are there is
reference to non regression in relation
to workers rights he says that the
protocol that the outline political
declaration does not have references to
what we were proposing in terms of a
free trade area for the future in fact
that is explicitly what it does
reference in the protocol it sets out
very clearly that we will be creating a
free trade area between the United
Kingdom and the European Union and then
I really not sure what document the
right honourable gentleman read because
he said the work there wasn't references
to extradition there are indeed
references to extradition and he said he
said also he said there was nothing
about Europol whereas there is expressly
a reference that we will be including in
the future document terms for the United
Kingdom's cooperation via Europe
and euro just and I say I say to the say
to the right honourable gentleman there
is there is indeed a choice between a
choice before members of this house it
is a choice of whether or not we go
ahead with a deal that does deliver on
the vote while protecting jobs while
protecting our security and while
protecting our dunya of course what the
right honourable gentleman wants is for
us to stay in the single market and stay
in the customs union which would which
would not deliver on the vote of the
referendum we are delivering an end to
free movement coming out of the Common
Agricultural Policy out of the CFP and
taking back control of our money borders
and our laws that is the right deal for
Britain and it is the deal that we will
be putting forward before this house mr.
Kenneth Clark mr. speaker it was been a
breakfast here illusion that the country
can leave the treaties the European
Union treaties while selecting to retain
all the benefits that we enjoy under the
treaties and repudiating most if not all
of the obligations and we have to face
up to that fact that's an illusion it
does my right on will friend Prime
Minister agree that the biggest single
economic benefit effect most of the main
bet to make benefits that we've enjoyed
from our membership over the last
decades flow from the completely open
border between the whole of the United
Kingdom and the rest of the European
Union and that upon that have been based
huge flows of inward investment the
creation of just in time lines of supply
and very many thousands of jobs in this
country so will she undertake that we
will not change the present basis of
that which is the single market and the
customs union until we know what we're
changing to
and until we're satisfied that any
change will retain those benefits and
keep completely open from any delays and
costs caused by regulatory differences
or anything else which will be created
by moving away from where we are now and
threaten the economic future of this
country very considerably if we just
decide unilaterally to walk out as some
of my colleagues seem prepared to
recommend Prime Minister my honorable
learned friend we have indeed heard from
business a very clear message about the
importance of frictionless borders which
is precisely why the proposal that the
United Kingdom has put forward to the
European Union is based on that concept
of frictionless borders and the free
trade area that we have put forward is
precisely in that frame my right
honourable and learned friend talks
about remaining in the single market in
the customs union I do not believe that
is right for the future of the United
Kingdom because I do not believe that
doing those things would deliver on the
vote of the British people I think the
British people wanted there are various
things that underpinned the vote an end
to free movement was crucial among those
also remaining in the customs union does
not enable us to have an independent
trade policy I believe it's important
that we do have an independent trade
policy once we have left the European
Union we're negotiating the basis of our
future trading relationship but it's
based on the concept of a free trade
area and precisely the point he makes
about being able to move Goods
seamlessly across the border in
Blackford
[Applause]
Thank You mr. speaker and can I thank
the Prime Minister for advanced site of
a statement mr. speaker the Prime
Minister comes before us today trying to
sell us a deal that is already dead in
the water
not even her own brexit secretary could
stand over it no mr. speaker to lose one
brexit secretary is one thing to lose
two in a matter of months eliminates the
chaotic nature of this Tory government
the number of ten front-door has become
a revolving worry
you know the Prime Minister talks about
taking back control she can even control
her own as I said yesterday the Prime
Minister is desperate and is
increasingly looking defeated what is
absolutely shocking as that Scotland is
not once mentioned in the document not
once once got the unique characteristics
of Scotland's DeVault settlements being
worthy of mention or dare the leader of
the Scottish National Party must be
heard and heard with courtesy and indeed
very grateful for your sedentary
observations mr. Graham but I do you
think they greatly add to the quality of
our deliberations everybody will be
heard mr. Ian Blackford Thank You mr.
speaker
not once has Scotland's unique
characteristics and a divorce settlement
been worthy of mention and yet 100
mentions of Northern Ireland mentions of
Gibraltar of Cyprus of the Isle of Man
but no reference to Scotland
so contempt has once again been shown to
the Scottish government its Parliament
and its people mr. speaker differentiy
deals for Northern Ireland means
Scotland can have its own differential
deal if Northern Ireland can stay in the
single market
why not Scotland Prime Minister the
Scottish government have published
compromised documents calling for
justice the Scottish Parliament has
affirmed that position why does the
Prime Minister ignore the democratically
expressed position of the Scottish
Government what has happened to the
claim of a partnership of equals why are
the desires of Scotland been ignored
when we know that a deferential
settlement can be delivered why does the
Prime Minister stand in the face of the
legitimate demands of the Scottish
Government and the Scottish Parliament
well you know the Prime Minister can
shake her head but it's a matter of fact
it's a matter of reality show some
respect to the devolved institutions
[Music]
the price
[Applause]
you can be and you can shout and you can
talk about it be in dreadful but why was
the Scottish government not consulted
just as Gibraltar was before the Prime
Minister went to cabinet yesterday mr.
speaker the price Scotland would be
forced to pay is far too high with lost
jobs household incomes slashed and our
NHS under threat now is the time to get
realistic and put sensible options back
on the table such as remaining in the
single market mr. speaker the only
credible compromise for which the SNP
has consistently made the case for this
deal is dead in the water it is now
clear that there is not a majority for
this deal or a No Deal
the Prime Minister must go back to
Brussels and extend article 50 and tell
Brussels that we must remain in this
single market and the customs union
anything else mr. speaker will lead to
economic chaos and crisis Prime Minister
do the right thing and we will work with
you stop the clock and go back to
Brussels
Prime Minister can I just pick up two
key points that the right honourable
gentleman first of all he made a
reference to Scotland's NHS being under
threat in fact Scotland's NHS depends on
the Scottish government the SNP
government determining the money is no
it's no good in pointing he's no good in
pointing his finger at me we we ensure
that in the NHS settlement the bonnet
i's settlement means more money comes to
Scotland and Scotland has chosen not to
spend it all on their NHS that's an
that's an SNP decision just to order I
saw I protected the right honourable
gentleman quite properly a moment ago
when he was being prayed at in an
unseemly manner but having asked the
question let me say to members of
Scottish national body they must hear
the Prime Minister's reply with courtesy
don't worry everybody will get a chance
but the Prime Minister's responses must
be heard with a basic courtesy and
respect the Prime Minister I was then
going to pick up the points that he made
in relation to Northern Ireland Northern
Ireland is not staying in the single
market what has what is within the
documents is that in order to ensure the
frictionless trade across the border
between North Ireland and Ireland
Northern Ireland will be meeting those
regulations specifically in the goods
part of the of the ickey but it is not
staying as a member of the single market
and he talks about Scotland being given
the same treatment as Northern Ireland
Northern Ireland has a very particular
set of circumstance it is it is the only
part of the United Kingdom that will
have a land border with a country that
is continuing as a member of the
European Union and that is why that is
why together with our commitments in the
Belfast agreement that is why Northern
Ireland is dealt with is dealt with
separately in the withdrawal agreement
and then finally he complained much of
his statement was a complaint that
Scotland was not specifically mentioned
in these documents Scotland is not
specifically mentioned Scotland is a
part of the United
mr. Ian Duncan Smith can I say that I
have always wished well to my right
honourable friend and my question is in
this light to say that I have deep deep
misgivings on reading a much of this
overnight that there is a real issue
with the way that we will be treated in
with the backstop and I say to her that
when you read this you realize that we
are locking ourselves in to an
arrangement from which we seem unable
therefore to have the sovereign right to
withdraw that seems to me to be the
biggest single issue here which strips
away the one thing that we said when we
wanted a vote for leaving was that we
took back control so can I say to my
Rhydon girlfriend my concern is that we
have the sovereign right when we want to
leave the UN we have the sovereign right
when we want to leave NATO we have even
the sovereign right when we want to
leave the EU but we do not have the
sovereign right to leave this
arrangement Minister my right honourable
friend for his and he says that the
references to the backstop do raise some
difficult issues my fully accept that
they raised some difficult issues and I
fully accept that across the house there
are concerns in relation to the backstop
indeed I share some of those concerns
these have not been easy decisions to
take it has been necessary as I
explained and it would be necessary in
any sir in any deal that we were
striking for our future partnership with
the European Union to agree a withdrawal
agreement and it has been clear and we
wanted to commit to ensure that we
delivered no hard border between north
now in Ireland it has been clear that
that withdrawal agreement needed to
include this insurance policy but if I
may say to my right honourable friend
first of all he talks about being held
in the backstop first of all the
backstop is not necessarily what will
happen because we want to ensure that
the future relationship is in place
before the backstop is necessary
secondly it will be a choice as to
whether we were to go in that
circumstance where there was a temporary
an interim period
needed before the future relationship
came into place we would be able to
choose a preference between the backstop
and the extension of the implementation
period there are pros and cons on both
of those sides of the arguments and
there will be honourable members who
have a you know a belief that one is
better than the other there is a
mechanism for coming out of the back
stop if the backstop is in place coming
out of the protocol that is a mechanism
that does and he's right it does require
mutual consent it is for both sides to
agree that it is it is and I won't make
any note make any bones about that but
it does enable that backstop to be
replaced in a number of circumstances
firstly of course crucially if the
future relationship supersedes it it
used to be the case it was the case of
reach originally that that was the only
point at which it could be superseded it
is now the case that alternative
arrangements could replace it but I
repeat I repeat what I have always said
which is that it is my intention to work
to ensure that such an arrangement is
not necessary and we are able to go into
our future relationship when we come out
of the implementation period so Vincent
cable the prime minister rightly asserts
that there are two alternatives to her
plan no deal and no black service the
government is investing considerably in
contingency planning for No Deal
what contingency planning is she doing
for nil brexit including for example
advising the commission that article 15
may have to be withdrawn and she
yourself preparing for the fact however
much she hates it that the house may
instruct her to carry out a people's
[Music]
he asked me what plans were making for
no brexit we are making no plans for no
brexit because this government is going
to deliver on the votes of the British
people John redwood if we took the best
part of 39th billion over the next
couple of years and spent it on public
services and tax cuts wouldn't that be a
wonderful boost to our economy in the
public mood and wouldn't that be a
better way of spending the money than
buying 21 months
order order this is extremely
discourteous the right honourable
gentleman has a right to be heard
without being shouted down while he's
speaking I invite the right honourable
gentleman to begin his question again
and to deliver it in full mr. John
redwood
Mr Speaker I was saying wouldn't it be a
wonderful boost to our economy in our
public services if we spend that money
on ourselves rather than on 21 months of
delay massive business uncertainty and
something which would sour the political
and the public mood for the whole time
period prime minister I say to my right
honourable friend as I said at a very
early stage of these negotiations the
United Kingdom is a country which meets
its legal obligations that says a great
deal about the sort of country that we
are and there are legal obligations as I
said in my statement that some of money
that he's referred to is considerably
less than the European Union was
originally proposing we would be
required to pay as part of the financial
settlement but I remain firmly of the
view that this is a country that should
ensure that we continue to meet our
legal obligations and we will do so mr.
Nigel Dobbs
Mr Speaker I could today stand here and
take the Prime Minister through the list
of promises and pledges which he made to
this house and to us privately about the
future of Northern Ireland in the in the
future relationship with the EU but I
fear it would be a waste of time since
she clearly doesn't listen and can I say
today that this house now has a clear
choice and every member in
that this host has been left in a
position where the choices subjection to
the rules and roles of others he may not
have our interests at heart and for
Northern Ireland and for our precious
union five of those who resigned today
have all talked about the threat to the
integrity of the Union and I
congratulate them and praise them for
what they have said and done and their
strong actions and 39 billion has just
been sad for nothing the choice is now
clear we stand up for the United Kingdom
the whole of the United Kingdom the
integrity of the United Kingdom or we
vote for a vassal state with the breakup
of the United Kingdom not your choice
Prime Minister
and I say - I will respond to thee to
the right to the right honorable
gentleman and he is right he and I have
had many discussions on this issue and I
hope that we will continue to be able to
have many discussions on this issue we
have been ensuring throughout the
negotiations that the issue of the
border in Northern Ireland has been one
of the key issues that we have been
addressing he refers to the commitments
I made in terms of Northern Ireland in
the future relationship those
commitments remain absolutely we are
looking to ensure that we have that
friction is trade across borders that
both will enable not only us to deliver
on our commitment for Northern Ireland
but will also enable us to ensure that
we have that frictionless trade between
the United Kingdom and the European
Union as the whole of the the rest of
the European Union as well
I believe that and I there are many
aspects of the deal that we have agreed
that actually ensure that we are
preserving the integrity of the United
Kingdom there has been a significant
focus on the question of the backstop as
I say the backstop isn't something which
neither side neither the United Kingdom
nor the European Union wish to ever see
being exercised but there are and indeed
in the circumstances as I've said where
there needs to be a period before the
future relationship is introduced there
are alternative routes that can be taken
but if the right honourable gentleman
says to me that he's concerned that we
have not considered Northern Ireland
throughout this process I can well I'm
grateful to him that he says he's not
said that because I have remained
committed to delivering on to things
from Northern Ireland both know hard
border between Northern Ireland and
Ireland at sorry three things no
hardboard working north ireland and
Ireland for us to be able to continue to
maintain and respond to our obligations
under the Belfast agreement and to
ensure that we protect the integrity of
the United Kingdom
Alice uber II as mr. speaker mr. speaker
nobody but nobody can doubt the Prime
Minister's absolute commitment and
dedication to doing her duty and trying
to deliver the only result of a
referendum but the harsh cruel truth of
it is is that this is not the promised
deal the reason why the people of this
country are so fed up is because they've
been made so many promises none of which
have been delivered upon because they
can't be delivered at all I agree with
the Prime Minister we face three choices
we either accept this agreement and I
respectfully suggest there is now no
maturity for it or we have no deal which
would be profoundly irresponsible and
catastrophic for our countries all we
have no brexit we remain in the European
Union the best deal that we have with
the European Union and on that basis
would she at least today undertake not
to rule out taking this back to the
British people
Prime Minister I'm afraid on that
particular issue I will disappoint my
right honourable friend I'm not going to
change the position I've taken in this
house and indeed taken more widely I
believe that it is the duty of members
of this Parliament to ensure that we
deliver on the choice that was made by
the British people a choice that this
Parliament overwhelmingly decided to
give them that means that we will not be
taking the option that she said of
remaining in the European Union but we
will indeed be leaving the European
Union and that will happen on the 29th
of March next year Hilary Bern
thank you very much mr. speaker the
Prime Minister has once again told the
house that we will be leaving the
customs union but the truth is that we
will be remaining in a customs union
both in the transition and in the
backstop arrangement which can only be
ended with the agreement of the EU and
the truth is also that the only way to
protect jobs investment and an open
border in Northern Ireland in the long
term is to remain within it will the
Prime Minister now unlock the British
people in the eye and admit that
remaining in a customs union is in our
national economic interests because
without it we will be poorer as it is in
our national interest is ensuring that
we continue to have a good trading
partnership with the European Union once
we have left that is why we have put
forward a proposal which is reflected in
the outline political declaration for a
free trade area in goods it is why we
have also put forward a proposal which
would ensure the frictionless trade of
goods across the border the right
honourable gentleman and I disagree a
customs union is not the only way to
ensure that we continue to have a good
trading relationship with the European
Union we've put forward a proposal that
is reflected in the outline political
declaration to do that while also
ensuring that we are able to take the
advantage of operating an independent
trade policy
Sir William cash
thank you these 585 pages are a
testament to broken promises failed
negotiations and abject capitulation to
the EU will my right will my right
honorable friend understand that they
represent in this of failures on
Northern Ireland's ecj issues indefinite
extension of time customs full
independence of trade and of Fisheries
and above all all are truly leaving the
EU because they will control our laws
and there have been furthermore some
very serious breaches of ministerial
responsibilities the mere serial code
and collective responsibility I say to
my honourable friend that they what we
are what we are looking at here is a
withdrawal agreement which determines
the withdrawal of the United Kingdom
from the European Union and the
declaration which identifies the scope
and structure of our future relationship
our future relationship is one that will
not see the European Union controlling
our laws because there will be in those
areas where we choose to align with the
European Union it will be for this
Parliament to decide that and that will
be a decision that will therefore be
taken here by the United Kingdom there
will not be European Court of Justice
jurisdiction in the United Kingdom and
that is what we have negotiated in the
outline political declaration for our
future relationship but I recognise but
I recognise my honourable friend as one
of the members of this house who has
campaigned on this issue probably since
the day maybe even since before he came
into this into this house and has
continued to campaign on this issue with
a passion and I recognize the concerns
that he has the concerns that he has
expressed as Prime Minister and as a
government it is our duty to ensure that
we could put together a deal that both
respects the vote of the British people
and it does in the ways that
I have said and attends free movement
also but does so in a way that protects
jobs that is why I believe it's
important not only that we take back
control in the areas mentioned but that
we maintain a good trade in relationship
with the European Union as well as
having good trading relationships
elsewhere that's in our economic
interest it's in our national interest
and that's what we will deliver that
Cooper the political declaration
includes the passenger named records and
the prom fingerprint database but makes
no reference to the crucial sis to
criminal database which we check 500
million times a year or to a replica
European arrest warrant at a time when
cross-border crime and security threats
are at their highest ever level the
Prime Minister knows that these measures
save lives stop criminals and stop
terrorists so how can she of all people
say with her head and her heart that
this public safety downgrade is in the
national interest
[Applause]
lady first of all of course there is
reference to us agreeing expeditious
Swift and effective arrangements to
enable the United Kingdom and member
states to extradite suspected and
convicted persons effectively and
expeditiously that is that will be a
part of exactly the measure or the
instrument that is used for that will be
part of the further negotiations that
will take place she's right sis to is
important to us there are two further
areas of exchange of information which I
in the Home Secretary believe are
importance is to indecorous and those
will be matters that we will be taking
forward with the European Union and our
further negotiations just in greening
greatly respect the Prime Minister's
efforts in seeking to achieve an
agreement I don't believe this is a good
deal for Britain's long term future and
she recognizes she's had to make
unpalatable choices there are clearly
three choices ahead of our country in
reality now and they are crucial choices
especially for young people
you will have to live with those choices
for the longest the Prime Minister said
this is in the national interest so why
not allow people in our nation to have
their say now if it was good enough
before why isn't it good enough now can
I say to my right humble friend and
indeed obviously this is right
honourable friend had already raised
this issue as have members on the
opposite benches this house chose to ask
the people of the United Kingdom whether
they wish to remain in the European
Union or leave the European Union there
was an overwhelming vote in parliament
to do that there was an overwhelming
vote in parliament to do that it was
about six to one so anybody says it
wasn't overwhelming is is wrong the
British people the British people
exercise their vote they exercise their
vote in numbers that we have never seen
before the result of that vote was that
we should leave the European Union and
it has always been my view as I've seen
in other European issue on other
European issues other countries other
member states of the European Union
taking matters back to their to their
populous having a referendum the vote
has come out against what the European
Union wanted and effectively has then
been at a mere a second fo to sort of go
back and think again vote I don't think
it's right that we should do that in
this country we gave people the choice
we should deliver on the decision they
talk
mr. Christopher Leslie it's quite clear
we've been going for about an hour now
not a single honorable writer remember
has supported the plans that the Prime
Minister has set out so it's quite clear
she cannot command the House of Commons
on these proposals in fact I'm almost
tempted to ask if the if honourable
members opposite will put their hands up
they actually do support the Prime
Minister on this set of proposals
in which case she says that remaining in
the European Union is an option how can
the British people fulfill that choice
if that is what they choose Yeah right
Minister I think sorry I apologize but I
didn't quite hear the question I think
the right honourable gentleman said
staying in the European Union was an
option but but no no I said I said I
said there was a risk of no brexit at
all I said there was a risk of no breaks
at all but what the government is
determined to do is to deliver on the
vote that the British people talk to
leave the European Union mr. Jacob Riis
MOG
mr. speaker my right honourable friend
and she is unquestionably honorable said
that we would leave the customs union
and x-two says otherwise
my right honourable friend said that she
would maintain the integrity of the
United Kingdom a whole protocol says
otherwise my right honourable friend
said that we would be out of the
jurisdiction of the European Court of
Justice asked 174 says otherwise as what
my right honourable friend says and what
my right on Wilfred does no longer match
should I not right to my right
honourable friend the member for ultrium
and sail west
[Applause]
can I say to my
animal friend
can I say to my honourable friend can I
say to my honourable friend we will
indeed he is referred to the Articles
that relate to the protocol in the
withdrawal agreement I have been
absolutely clear that some difficult
choices have had to be made in relation
to that protocol those choices have been
made because I believe and I strongly
and firmly believe it is important that
we do ensure that there is no hard
border between Northern Ireland and
Ireland but as I have said before my
honourable friend has heard me say
before it is not only our intention but
we will be working to ensure that that
protocol does not need to be put into
place what what we are negotiating
alongside that withdrawal agreement is
not something that will be of a
temporary nature but what will be a
lasting future relationship with the
European Union which will last for
decades to come and in that future
relationship we will no longer be a
member of the customs union we will no
longer be a member of the single market
an end to free movement will have been
delivered the integrity of the United
Kingdom will have been Mattea maintained
the jurisdiction of the European Court
of Justice in the United Kingdom will
have will end and we will come out of
the Common Agricultural Policy and the
Common Fisheries Policy as I asked my
honourable friend to consider the nature
of the future relationship that we will
be delivering with the European Union
which does indeed deliver on the
commitments that I've made
this is Jonathan Edwards with the
Northern Ireland potentially swimming in
the deep end of the pool can she
confirmed that based on the British
government's own logic no economic
economic border between we and England
would arise would my country decide to
front crawl down to them to the can I
say to the Honourable gentleman but of
course we're conscious as we look at the
proposals for the trading relationship
between the United Kingdom and the
European Union
I'm conscious of the significant trade
that takes place between Ireland and and
Wales and the importance this has for
the Welsh for the Welsh ports one of the
of course if you look at the future
relationship we have made a proposal for
that frictionless trade which would
indeed protect the business of the Welsh
ports and ensure that we have as part of
that good trading relationship for the
future
so peter Bottomly right foot to our
right over friend that the majority in
the country in his Parliament and in his
party except the results of the
referendum that we back her in trying to
get the sovereignty
she's argue for the prospects of
prosperity security and a fruitful
partnership across the channel the North
Sea and across the world and they'll
turn seas if we don't go through this or
the probability of crashing out and the
possibility of a government led by the
leader the opposition neither which the
alternative my friend
I believe as I as I think he does that
it is important for us to move forward
not only in delivering on the vote but
ensuring we do so in a way that does
protect our prosperity protects people's
jobs and and livelihoods for the future
but more than that there are significant
opportunities for this country and once
we leave the European Union to develop
that right a future with those further
trading relationships around the rest of
the world but also keeping a good
trading relationship with our closest
partners in the EU Angela Eagle Thank
You mr. speaker will the Prime Minister
now recognized that she made a
catastrophic error when she decided to
kowtow to the fantasy extremist beliefs
of the brexit ears in her own party
instead of bringing the country together
that their views are impossible to
actually bring about and they are now
openly plotting against her as she has
tried to do her best in this negotiation
surely she now needs to listen to the
fact that there is no majority in this
house for the botched deal she has
brought back think again and see whether
in this house there can be a consensual
way forwards which leaves her bricks
tree mists out in the cold I say to the
Honourable lady that I have kowtow to no
one the instruction I take the
instruction the instruction I take is
the instruction that was given to every
member of this house by the British
people in the referendum on 2016 mr.
mark Francoise thank you
it may surprise that but I agree with my
honourable friend from Broxton Prime
Minister the whole house accepts that
you have done your best but the Labour
Party have made plain today that they
will vote against this deal the SNP will
they the liberals will vote against it
the the DUP will vote against it our key
ally in this place will vote against it
over 80 Tory backbenchers well it's 84
now and it's going up by the owl will
vote against it
it is therefore mathematically
impossible to get this deal through the
house of Pama dismiss the stark reality
Prime Minister is that it was dead on
arrival at some Tommy's before you stood
up so I plead with you I plead with you
to accept the political reality
the situation you now face the honor I
say to the Honourable gentleman I I
respect the fact for teamers he'll also
holds very clear views on the issue of
our membership of the European Union and
the sort of relationship that we should
have with the European Union thereafter
we will go forward with the final
negotiations towards that European
Council meeting on the 25th of November
and when when a deal is brought back it
will be for members of this house not
just to look at the details of that deal
but to consider to consider the vote of
the British people to consider our duty
to deliver on the vote of the British
people this is the deal that has been
negotiated with the European Union we
have to finalize it and the vote will
come when we have a meaningful vote and
it will be two members of this house to
determine how they wish to vote at that
time and to remember when they cast
their vote the importance of ensuring
that we deliver on the boat of the
British people then Bradshaw the Prime
Minister will be aware that the main
financial backer of brexit mr. Aaron
banks is now under criminal
investigation by the National Crime
Agency because of serious doubts about
the true source of the money he spent on
the leave campaign did the Prime
Minister when she was Home Secretary in
2016 declined a request from the
security services for mr. banks to be
investigated for a minister to the right
honourable gentleman that of course we
do not comment in this house on
individual criminal investigations on
individual criminal investigations that
take place Nicky Morgan in this whole
brexit process and one of them is we
just heard that colleagues on these
benches are going to use the
parliamentary vote which 11 of us voted
for last December yep and received a
torrent of abuse
positions of treachery and betrayal and
threats of D selection yeah we've heard
so many times we are where we are I want
to pay tribute to the fact that the
Prime Minister did get agreement in
cabinet and can she reassure us that
regardless of however many ministerial
resignations there are between now and
that vote that the agreement will come
to Parliament and Parliament will have
it say and that she is clear that voting
for that agreement is in the national
interest that I can give her the
assurance that obviously we have the
step of the European Union Council and
finalizing the deal but a deal when
finalized will indeed be brought
Parliament and as I suggested earlier it
will be for every member of this house
to determine their vote in the national
interest but McFadden Prime Minister has
carried out permission on this with no
small sense of duty but it has been a
failure and it has turned out to be a
humiliation this was sold to the people
as taking back control but the promises
of the right-wing nationalists who drove
this have been shown to have turned to
dust instead we are being asked to sign
up to control of vast waves of our
economy with no say over them I'm paying
tens of millions for the privilege is it
not the case that far from taking back
control this is the biggest voluntary
surrender for sovereignty
to think again my answer to his question
is no and if we look at the situation
he'd refers to the 339 billion which of
course was the financial settlement that
is in the withdrawal agreement which is
which is part of the overall package of
the withdrawal agreement and the future
relationship and the future relationship
that we are negotiating with the
European Union is designed and the
outline political declaration makes this
clear to deliver on exactly the issues
that were to the British people when
they voted for brexit of course as well
said repeatedly in many times in this
house nothing is agreed until everything
is agreed Steve Baker this is completely
intolerable and I feel confident that
even in the unlikely event that
legislation for it reaches this house it
will be ferociously opposed will my
right and will friend therefore accept
that this deal could well be a choice by
the government to have no deal imposed
upon it at the last minute will she
therefore trigger all of the
implementation of No Deal No Deal
contingencies now here my Minister say
to my honourable friend that we as I
indicated earlier I think in response to
a previous question we will be in we
will be continuing the No Deal
preparations because I am conscious that
we have further stages to go in relation
to this process that European Union
Council and of course bringing this
matter back to this house and as he has
recognized that's not just the
meaningful vote but also the legislation
that then has to has to go through and
as I said earlier recognizing that we
have that European Council and that
meaningful vote to take place in this
house we will be continuing our no deal
preparations Stephen get in
[Music]
mr. speaker whilst it might be tempting
to watch the much-vaunted
Tory brags a festival this is deeply
serious stuff though the Prime Minister
knows that her Treasury's own analysis
means that every single one of her plans
means people losing their jobs so will
she look at the plan which means us
losing the least number of jobs which is
the least damaging and me unlike her
plan when supports across this house and
that's to remain part of the customs
union and the single market minister we
will be leaving the customs union and
leaving the single market
[Applause]
or leave whether we sit on this side of
the house or that we know that millions
of people voted for brexit because they
are anxious about their futures about
their children and about their families
away from the Westminster bubble we must
remember to consider these vast
communities when we consider the
outcomes today and we know that it is No
Deal that will be most damaging to them
the Prime Minister what the response is
well the response has been from the
business councils that she set up those
major employers in the country that will
protect those jobs
well thank my right honourable friend
for fazing focusing people's sights on
people outside of this chamber because
that is they are the people that we must
consider when we are looking at our
decisions in relation to this to this
deal when it comes forward can I just
say there have been quite a number of
quotes from that have come from industry
about the about the deal and about the
fact that for example it delivers a
clear path ahead that prison is so
desperately needs that it brings with it
some certainty that the Federation of
small businesses it brings with it some
certainty that our small businesses have
KREEP have craved business out there has
been looking for the certainty that a
deal will bring and they have also been
concerned that we focused our on that
free-trade area and on that frictionless
trade across borders which of course is
exactly what this government has done
Frank field can the Prime Minister
guarantee to the house but at the end of
mark we will continue to have
frictionless supply chains and at the
end of this process we will be in
control of our borders we point back the
judicial powers that we have surrendered
can I say them to the right honourable
gentleman that the future relationship
that we are negotiating with the
European Union absolutely delivers on
the points that he made about no
jurisdiction of the European Court of
Justice taking back control of our
borders so free movement is ended we
have also based the free trade the
concept of the free trade area on the
need for that frictionless trading goods
to ensure that people whose jobs depend
on those supply chains are do not see
those jobs go but we're not only able to
retain those jobs but with the other
trade agreements were able to bring
forward at once we're outside the
European unity can enhance the economy
and create more jobs in this country sir
nicholas sounds give me mr. speaker may
I congratulate the Prime Minister on her
exceptional efforts to honour the
results of the referendum and to achieve
a deal with the European Union under the
most difficult and demanding
circumstances and will she elaborate on
the scale and breadth of the future
partnerships agreed on security and
defence right honourable friend there
are two areas in relation to security
one of course is internal security on
which I've answered a number of
questions where we intend to maintain
cooperation in a number of areas where
we're currently working very closely
with our European partners the other is
in external security and defence and we
will have obviously our independent
foreign policy it will be for our
decisions but what we have negotiated
and is set out in the outline political
declaration is an ability for the United
Kingdom where it makes sense to do so to
work with our European partners on
matters of security and defence and on
issues like the imposition of sanctions
where it makes sense for those sanctions
actually to be Europe wider than simply
the European Union and the UK to be part
of that we will have our independent
ability to deliver on sanctions but we
will cooperate with our partners in the
European Union that is what retains our
independence but also ensures that we're
able to act at all times in the best
interests of the United Kingdom and the
best in
of maintaining our security and defense
Caroline Lucas Thank You mr. speaker the
Prime Minister knows her deal is dead
she knows that no deal would be a
disaster
so we risk chaos job losses
environmental rules torn up the NHS in
crisis
now that was never the will of the
people they did not vote for that this
isn't a parlor game it's real people's
real lives and those risks can only be
addressed if we put aside party politics
so I appeal to her again why will she
not give the people of this country a
vote of people's vote on where this
country goes most I could refer to the
Honorable aegis once as I've given
earlier but let me repeat the answer I
have given earlier which is that this
Parliament gave the people of vote the
people voted to leave and we will
deliver on the people's vote it would
lead with response with respect to my
honourable friend for North East
Somerset I believe these issues are so
complex that one should not deal with
them on a personal basis but my question
is this and will she help me in my
loyalty what if the brexit secretary is
Right what is what if his resignation
letter it's devastating resignation
letter is correct that we are likely or
possibly going to be locked permanently
in a backstop arrangement what if
therefore she loses this vote in
parliament which is very likely can she
promised me then whatever happens in his
vote she will deliver brexit at the end
of March
Minister can I say - can I say to my
honourable friend first of all that we
will be leaving the European Union on
the 29th of March 2019
and that is that is a set date and I am
determined that we will deliver on that
whatever happens whatever happens in in
between in relation to this question of
whether or not were we to be in the back
stop and as I've said the back stop is
not an arrangement that either side
actually wants to see being operated
that it was no more than a temporary
construct the row various there are
various aspects to this I will draw his
attention to - one or two of those first
of all the it is not possible under
article 50 under the legal basis of
article 50 under which this withdrawal
agreement is set for it to set a
permanent relationship for the future
and that is explicitly referred to
within their withdrawal agreement that
it does not establish a permanent
relationship and as I say that's
inherent in the operation of the article
50 legal base I would also say to my
honorable friends that one of the things
that we have got removed from this from
this protocol is the idea that was it
there at one stage that if we've moved
on to the future relationship and the
British government chose to change that
future relationship that the backstop
could be reinserted it cannot be once it
is superseded it cannot be revived Phil
Wilson can I congratulate the Prime
Minister she has proven yet again that
you cannot square a wheel come the Prime
Minister their force their hand on heart
whether she believes what she has
negotiated is better than the deal we
are now
Prime Minister I only believe that this
country's best days are ahead of us we
will get a good deal in the European
area we will get a good deal with the
European Union and take advantage of our
independence outside the European Union
with our trade deals around the rest of
the world
Stephen Crabb my own constituency like
the rest of the country is deeply
divided today does my right honourable
friend agree that there was always going
to come a really difficult moment when
the theory of a perfect brexit met the
cold reality of hard choices and
compromise but does she agree with me
that this is absolutely not a moment to
walk away from our responsibilities to
govern and provide this country with
leadership at this difficult honourable
gentlemen yes I do I do agree with him
this is this is a complex negotiation
this is a complex negotiation
it does require difficult choices to be
made and the challenge for all of us in
this house is to make those choices not
according to what we wish the world
could be like but to the reality of the
world that we see and to make those
choices pragmatically in the interests
of the British people
Rachel Reeves the Prime Minister insists
that this deal is in the national
interest so specifically on the economy
the agreement will ensure that we have
no say in the rules in which govern how
we trade it does not include services as
part of free and frictionless trade and
it offers only the illusion of future
trade deals given all this does the
Treasury believe that we will grow more
or less fast and create more or less
jobs with a negotiated agreement or with
our current relationship with the
European Union later she refers of
course to the withdrawal agreement what
is important in terms of the
relationship that will persist for
decades between this country and the
European Union is the future partnership
that we negotiate with the EU that is
based as we've said the Pro to the
outline political declaration is based
on the concept of a free trade area and
ensuring that we continue to have that
good trade relationship and I can assure
her as I've assured honourable members
across this house before that when the
meaningful vote is before this house
members will have the appropriate
analysis in order to inform them in
terming to their decision dr. Sarah
Wollaston
be blindingly obvious to the entire
country but the Prime Minister's deal
cannot pass this house what they will
find unforgivable is that we are running
out of Road and in in hundred and thirty
four days when we be crashing out of the
European Union with no deal and no
transition with catastrophic
consequences for all the communities
that we represent in this house could I
urge the Prime Minister again to think
again about whether at this stage we
should go back to the people present
them with the options on regardless into
something that will have such profound
implications for all of our lives Prime
Minister the nature of the brexit of our
future relationship with the European
Union will be a matter of course that
will come before this house in the vote
that this house will take and members of
this house will have various issues to
consider when they take that vote but I
would say to my honourable friend as I
have said to other honourable members
honorable and right honourable members
of this house that I firmly believe that
having given the choice as to whether we
should leave the EU to the British
people it is right and proper and indeed
our duty as a parliament and as a
government to deliver on that vote this
candle we now know that during the
transition which may well have to be
extended that the UK will give up our
sail over the rules that govern large
parts of our economy and if the backstop
comes into play
we won't unilaterally be able to leave
it how is giving up our current say and
influence for no say and influence
taking about control
and I say to the honourable lady that
indeed but what she describes in
relation to the transition period was
clear I've Anson's answered questions in
this house on it went back in March when
the European Council agreed the concept
of the transition period so that was
absolutely clear the point of that
transition period is moving towards the
future relationship and the future
relationship is one in which we will
have the ability to determine our
position yes we put forward two proposal
in the white paper which had
frictionless trade and a common rulebook
but aside that alongside that common
rule book was a parliamentary lock on
determining whether or not this country
would accept any changes in those rules
mr. Peter bone thank you thank you mr.
speaker and the government is preparing
to give 39 billion pounds to the EU and
there's no legal obligation to do so and
we are going to get nothing in return
that is 60 million pounds for each and
every constituency in this country so if
I had 60 million pounds in
Wellingborough I would have the Isham
bypass I have our roads mended properly
I'd have an urgent care center but the
iceberg hospital and I have would have
millions of pounds over pleased Prime
Minister use that money in this country
not give it to the EU minister and the
premise of his question was that there
is no legal obligation for us to pay
anything to the European Union I have to
say I believe that is not the case I
believe there are legal obligations for
this country in relation to the
financial settlement with the European
Union and as I said earlier I believe
that as a country we are a country that
abides by our legal obligations Tom
break the this deal is not in the
national interest and the Prime Minister
knows that it leaves us less secure less
influential and more isolated but could
I ask the prime minister on the subject
of
no wrecks it at all could she set out
what scenarios would lead to no brexit
at all as far as I can tell there only
to one she calls a gentle action which I
assume she won't be doing or to she
allows a people's vote so which of those
two is it going to be Minister the right
honourable gentleman he refers to what
he described what he thinks the position
is going to be for the United Kingdom if
we go ahead with this with this deal and
he talks about us being more isolated
that will not be the case the United
Kingdom the United Kingdom will be
taking its continuing to play its role
on the world stage in a whole variety of
organisations that will be involved in
but also in the way in which we
negotiate trade deals with the rest of
the world in the way in which we support
and cooperate with parts of the rest of
the world on matters like security and
defence there is no sense in which this
United Kingdom is going to be isolated
when we leave the European Union
antoinette Sandbach thank you speaker
for many months this house was assured
that it would have the full future
framework before it when it was voted on
the withdrawal agreement I was
encouraged to hear the Prime Minister
say that further detail will emerge as
that will be critical for the jobs and
employment in my constituency can the
Prime Minister outline when we will see
that full future framework can I I
thanked my own boyfriend because this
gives me an opportunity to to set out
the process that will be followed we
will be now entering into intense
further intense negotiations with the
European Union such that a full of
future framework can be delivered to the
European Council as part of the overall
package and that will then of course be
published and available for members of
this house to see and I'm conscious that
it is important while we can't agree
legal texts on the future relationship
because we cannot do that until we have
left the European Union that we have
sufficient detail in that future
framework that members are able to have
confidence in the future relationship
with the European Union when they come
to vote
in on the meaningful vote it's very
Sherman or her parliamentary career I
don't always agree with her but I know
her to be a woman of courage and I feel
sorry with her this morning let down by
the disloyalty of so many of her
colleagues and I also feel sorry for her
because we have actually given her an
impossible task we know increasingly in
this country and in this house that
there is no deal better than staying in
the European Union I do this time we do
something to recognize and be courageous
and take it back to the people
[Music]
the right honorable gentleman will not
be surprised that the answer I give him
despite the fact that we have known each
other throughout my career in this house
will be no different from that that I've
given to other honorable and right
honourable members of this house in
relation to taking the vote back to the
people it was a decision of this
Parliament by six to one that the people
should have that choice and they
exercised their votes as I said earlier
in numbers that we've not seen before
and I think it is only right and proper
that this that this Parliament that this
government delivers on that vote the
good doctor
dr. Julian Lewis can the Prime Minister
describe any sure away of frustrating
the referendum result and ultimately
remaining in the European Union than to
accept a Hotel California brexit deal
which ensures that we can never truly
leave the EU with all its manipulative
entangling and undemocratic practices
I say to my honourable friend we are
leaving the European Union on the 29th
of March 2019 we are negotiating a
future relationship with the European
Union that will indeed deliver on the
vote of the British people that took
place in the the referendum and we will
do so because we will bring an end to
free movement an end to the jurisdiction
of the Court of Justice of the European
Union come out of the Common
Agricultural Policy out of the Common
Fisheries Policy these are issues that I
have referred to previously but we will
be leaving on the 29th of March 2019
Luciana bersia because the withdrawal
agreement that the Prime Minister is
presenting to us today is not in the
national interest and it's very clear is
he's not going to make us better off she
may not be aware that there's been an
overnight you got called that shows that
63% of the British public are against
this deal with 64% favoring of people's
vote if the deal is rejected which is
very clear from the contributions this
morning is what is going to happen in
this house will she now listen to the
millions of people across my country and
give them a say on what bricks it will
actually mean rather than on the false
promises that the vote to leave was
predicated upon the Honourable lady that
the documents actually were published
yesterday evening which 500 pages of the
Thrall Agreement plus the outline
political declaration and the joint
statement but she once again the
assumption is that we should in some
sense try to go back on the vote that
the British people took I believe
absolutely that we should not and that
we should ensure that we do leave the
European Union that was the decision
that was taken by the British people and
that's the decision we would deliver on
and dr. Phillip Lee when I resigned from
the government in June I called for the
suspension of article 50 because I
feared this likely parliamentary impasse
I know the primary that Prime Minister
is a thoroughly decent person who has
public service running through her veins
with that in mind and with an eye on the
importance of the responsible the
responsibility of government could the
Prime Minister outline to me the legal
the legislative and political
requirements of suspending article 50 or
indeed revoking it I think my honourable
friend will will know there is of course
the case but that has been in case
before the courts on the relation on the
issue of the extension of article 50 but
this government's position is clear we
will not extend article 50 Joanna
cheering Prime Minister articles 14 87
89 1 5 8 and 174 of this Agreement mean
that the jurisdiction of the European
Court of Justice will continue to reign
supreme across the UK in a number of
respects for four years after the
transition period in some respects for
eight years after the transition period
in other respects and in the case of
Northern Ireland indefinitely can she
tell us in what respects her red line on
the court of justice survived this
agreement say to the Honorable lady that
the yes and I was very clear when we
brought back the agreement in December
in the joint report in relation to
citizens rights for example that the
would continue to be an ability for the
interpretation of European Court of
Justice in relation to European Union
law on those rights to be considered for
a period of time beyond the end of the
transition period and then that will
that will cease in relationship or
knowledge it is not the case that
Northern Ireland will be indefinitely
under the jurisdiction of the European
Court of Justice the future relationship
that we are negotiating with the
European
we'll ensure that the United Kingdom
will be removed from the jurisdiction of
the European Court of Justice if she
looks at the governance arrangements
that have been put in that are proposed
to be put in place it is we are very
clear that the court of one party cannot
determine matters in relation to the
court of relation to another party so
Christopher choke - bull friend has
repeated today that nothing is agreed
until everything is agreed so can I
write on ghoulfriend explain why there
is nothing in their withdrawal
agreements which makes the with drawl
agreement legally contingent upon the
implementation and agreement of a legal
relationship for the future my
honourable friend that there are indeed
of course clauses which link the
withdrawal agreement to the to the
future relationship and to ensuring that
both sides will be and the Libra term of
best endeavours is used in a number of
places in relation to this matter to
ensure that that future relationship is
in place obviously we as I've said
earlier we are still going to be
negotiating further details in relation
to that to that future relationship and
it is the determination of both sides as
expressed in these documents that that
future relationship should be capable of
being put into place at the end of the
transition period okay we made a very
dignified statement in very difficult
circumstances but does she actually
realize that outside this house when
people read these hundreds of pages of
Bureau speak that they will realize that
in a way we are being sold out we've
been sold out by our negotiators who
have allowed the EU to take the lead
will she not accept that at this stage
not only are we all being collectively
civilized but the people of Northern
Ireland are being sold out absolutely
relating that I do not I do not agree
with her in relation to the suggestion
that in some sense the European
Commission the European Union has given
nothing away to the UK during these
negotiations
these have been tough negotiations this
is a complex matter but for example as I
referred to in my statement the EU has
been clear for some time that the choice
we had in our future relationship was
binary between the Norway model or the
Canada model they have now accepted that
is not the case and there is a bespoke
agreement for the United Kingdom they
said we couldn't share security
capabilities as it's clear in the
outline political declaration we do have
access to certain security capabilities
they said that we couldn't preserve the
invisible border between Northern
Ireland and Ireland without splitting
the UK's customs territory that is now
no longer the case these are all issues
that our negotiators have negotiated in
the interest of the United Kingdom
Stephen Hammond the boost to our economy
that was referred to earlier and the
necessary protection for our positions
jobs can only occur if UK industry has a
frictionless trade area and deep
regulatory cooperation but UK financial
services in UK industry also need
certainty yeah so would my right
honourable friend confirm to the house
that the future political framework will
contain a common rulebook and a deep
customs arrangement as my as my
honourable friend has seen from the
outline political declaration it makes
reference to the free trade area that we
will be negotiating with the with the
European Union and indeed to the need to
ensure that we have those good
arrangements across our border as was
outlined in the joint statement that
accompanied the outline political
declaration there are two areas where in
particular where further negotiation is
continuing one of them is on this issue
in relation to the trade relationship
the other is as I indicated in my
response to the right honourable lady
the member of Pontefract that actually
there are aspects of the security
relationship that we are continuing to
but we continue to work on the basis
that my right honourable friend has set
out of the importance of that
frictionless trade across borders mr.
David Lammy the right honourable lady
has been a professional colleague for
over 20 years
and I personally saw how hard she worked
during the 2011 riots this whole house
recognizes the dedication and hard work
she has put into this 585 page agreement
however because of her huge
parliamentary experience they also
recognize that this Agreement does not
command a majority in this house and
that in the 10 days to follow before the
EU signed off this agreement she will
likely face challenges within her own
party in those circumstances in our
constitutional arrangements when
politics is broken one can only put the
question back to the British people I
think I think having having taken pad to
the vote in 2016 I think the British
people will look at this chamber will
look at this house
will look at this Parliament and will
say what people say to me when I go on
the doorsteps and talk to them actually
we've taken the decision to leave just
get on with it
just deliver
dr. Caroline Johnson Thank You mr.
speaker from history you said that it
will be our choice whether we go into an
implementation period or a backstop if
the agreement cannot be reached but in
the in this document it says the if the
protocol gives the UK a choice to either
implement the backstop or seek an
extension of the implementation code
which it does by requesting that so how
is that our choice and not that it is it
is our choice as to which of those we
wish to do it is absolutely right and my
only friend is right that that extension
of the implementation period does need
to have agreement with the with the
European Union and that is why I have
described this as a choice it is for us
to say whether we wish the backstop or
the implementation period to be extended
but she's absolutely right that
extension would be a matter of
negotiation with the European Union
there are and there are arguments on
both sides for if we get to that point
as to which of those would be preferable
for the United Kingdom just as actually
there will be arguments on both sides
for the European Union because the
backstop is not actually an area and not
a situation which the European Union
wants to get into either very Cray Mr
Speaker I have a great deal of sympathy
for the Prime Minister she has walked
the Via Dolorosa that has been set out
for her by her own party but the the
false choice that she is offering this
place is between a deal that is dead
before it
even been read by most people in this
house or no deal at all isn't it time
now for the British people to take back
control from this place for her to
extend article 50 and let the people
decide
in a previous vote I have say to the
Honourable lady I refer her to the
answers I gave previously to those
questioned mr. Richard Drax to speak up
my right my friend who tells the house
that again to March 19 we are going to
leave the EU we've also heard from
herself
and from both sides of the house that
actually that is not the case worse
about this deal and would you respect
one friend right on my friend we have no
way no unilateral way of leaving and
were still there is no incentive there
at all for the EU to let us go
can I say to my honourable friend we
will be leaving the European Union on
the 29th of March 2019 after that date
we will no longer be a member of the
European Union yes we have agreed in the
transition period that the operation the
way we operate with the European Union
will continue very much as it is today
and that is in order to ensure that
there is no cliff edge for business at
the point of the 29th of March so that
business can adapt to the changes that
come in relation to our future
relationship there is and that is I
repeat we will no longer from the 29th
of March 2019 be a member of the
European Union this is Marian fellows
during the course of yesterday and
excluding her own cabinet can the Prime
Minister tell the house which
organizations and individuals we're
informed and briefed on our proposed
deal in which order 3 briefed and what
process of hierarchy was applied to the
Honourable lady that the members of the
cabinet came together yesterday to look
at the withdrawal agreement and at the
outline political declaration the
information was made available to the
members of the cabinet once the text had
been finalized negotiations carried on
up to quite a late time in relation to
those negotiations and the cabinet was
able to take its decision on the basis
of proper papers Sir Desmond Swain why
did she say that rejecting the deal of
risks no brexit can she quantify that
risk and say how it might occur say to
the the honourable gentleman that I
think he will be aware that there may be
those in this house has been have heard
indeed from a number of honourable
members on the opposition benches who do
wish to try to ensure that we do not
leave the European Union I believe it is
important that we do leave the EU
we do so on the basis of a good future
relationship with the EU Peter Coyle
it is obvious that she is not commanding
a majority in the house people who
supported leave know that this deal
gives power to the EU not brings it back
and people who support remain know that
the deal she is offering is not as good
as the one we have we have got to this
position because she has been playing
games with Braves it from the beginning
including calling a general election in
their mid week the middle of the
negotiation clearly will she now do the
right thing and go back to the people
and let them say if this deal is good as
it's good enough for them this is not a
rerun of the referendum the first one
was based on promises this one will be
based on fatfat I refer the Honourable
gentleman to the answer I gave earlier
Nick Herbert very much mr. speaker
is there not a danger than in getting
hung up on issues such as the backstop
which though immensely important are is
something that we actually on all sides
wish to avoid or issues such as the
transition period which are by
definition temporary that in getting
hung up on these issues we lose sight of
the really important issue which is the
future relationship with the EU that is
what we should be focusing on and
discussing and that is what our
constituents expect us to deliver and is
it not the case that the vast majority
of members of this house however they
voted in the referendum voted to trigger
article 50 and the public expect us to
deliver on that promise and members on
this side in particular should be
careful what they wish for in making it
harder to move to that position
[Applause]
can I support the comments that my right
honourable friend has made and he is
absolutely right
of course there's been a lot of focus on
the backstop and I recognize why there's
been a lot of focus on the backstop
because there are genuine concerns about
the operation of the backstop and of
course as he says others have referenced
the transition or implementation period
but what actually will determine our
relationship with the European Union for
decades ahead is the future relationship
that we negotiate with the European
Union that is what will determine the
futures of his constituents of my
constituents and other people across the
whole United Kingdom order opportunity
to inform the house that we have now had
50 questions from backbenchers so may I
please appeal to colleagues to put short
and pointed questions as exemplified by
the right honourable gentleman the
member for New Forest West Jack dreamy
no deal would have catastrophic
consequences for UK manufacturing this
deal will not pass Parliament why does
the Prime Minister persist in seeking to
achieve the unachievable because with
every day of delay we're one step closer
to the cliff and to go over that cliff
with our agreement would be the ultimate
betrayal of the British national
interests that when it comes to the
House of course members of this house
will have a choice as to whether to
accept the deal I understand that most
manufacturers have actually welcomed the
deal they recognise that this is a step
forward in ensuring we can deliver on
what matters to them for the future
relationship in the future trade in
partnership with the EU the key board
mr. speaker many of the questions put by
colleagues today would be addressed if
there was more detail on the future
relationship but of course it's been the
EU negotiators
and not the British negotiators who've
refused to discuss the future
relationship before the withdrawal
agreement so
thank the Prime Minister for this
outline of the future relationship and
can she clarified that we will get more
detail on that future relationship
before the critical vote in this house
yes I'm very happy to confirm that to my
honourable friend as she refers to the
position of the EU negotiators in fact I
think for many they feel that they have
being looking at perhaps more of the
future relationship than they had
expected but we will ensure that there
is more detail available for members of
this house before the meaningful vote
Chikara muna a mr. speaker the Prime
Minister has said the country faces
three choices
no brexit any agreement that she is able
to finalize with the EU and get through
this house and No Deal
she's also just said that we will get an
economic analysis and impact assessment
will she undertake to ensure that that
impact assessment includes a comparison
between the current deal we have no
brexit and the one she is proposing to
put before this house in a meaningful
vote to withhold that from this house
would be unacceptable I say to the
honourable gentleman that we will ensure
that when the time comes for people to
indeed in advance of the time that
people will be taking their decision in
relation to the meaningful vote that
proper analysis will be available to
make people enable people to make a
judgment a judgment between the deal
that is being proposed and between
alternative arrangements andrew bridden
the prime minister is well known for her
dancing sadly having seen the withdrawal
agreements not clear who's - she's been
dancing to my right honourable friend
campaigned for remain she voted remain
now surely it's in the national interest
for her to leave perhaps following a
short transition period set out
- my honourable friend can I can I note
the way in which he has carefully tried
to weave into his question various
references to matters that are not
perhaps entirely relevant to the
withdrawal agreement and the political
declaration now every member of this
house will have a decision to take when
the deal is brought back I believe it is
important that we have a deal which does
deliver on the vote of British people
which I believe the deal does but does
that in a way that protects jobs
protects people's security and of course
protects the integrity of our United
Kingdom as a McGovern truly a sad day
for our country government is collapsing
whilst we are riddled with food banks
child poverty Rises and 30% of workers
are in hardship jobs what in the three
pages of wishlist here should the Prime
Minister suggest that will change the
fortunes of this country for the better
I say to the Honourable lady first of
all we see that absolute poverty is in
fact at a low what we see is what we
have seen what we have seen in the law
in the figures that have come out
earlier this week is that real wages
have been growing faster recently than
any time in the last decade or so the
portrayal that she has set out of this
country is not a fair portrayal what she
says what is going to what is going to
ensure and improve the futures of the
British people well first of all getting
a good trade deal with the European
Union is important that's what we're
working to that's what the outline
political declaration sets out but also
ensuring that we can have those good
trade deals around the rest of the world
but I have to point out of hope to have
given the benches that she sits on but
what is necessary for all of that is the
good economic management that the
Conservative government has produced
so Geoffrey Clifton Brown have no doubt
that my right honourable friend has in
good faith negotiated the best deal on
this withdrawal agreement that she could
it doesn't please Brussels it doesn't
please London and it probably doesn't
please any member of this house but
nevertheless do we not owe it to the
British people to carefully scrutinize
it together with the remaining documents
that she will bring back from the summit
in November to see whether it is in the
best interest of the British people
rather than crashing out of the EU with
no deal can I say to my right honourable
friend I think it is important that as I
say there is some further negotiation to
fill out the details of the future
relationship and as he says it will be
important for members of this house to
consider those documents when they have
when they take the meaningful vote
alongside the analysis that will be
provided by government so that they have
the full information to be able to take
that vote and as he says recall in
taking that vote the duty that I believe
we have to deliver on the vote that was
taken in the referendum it's clear that
this deal is not as as good as the one
we currently have it will make the
country worse off and it's clear that
there is no majority in the house for
her Deal or No Deal and the Prime
Minister has ruled out extending article
50 or a people's vote so what is the
plan in the event of not getting support
in the house for her deal the Honourable
lady will know the process that has been
set set by this house in relation to
that matter but can I can I also say to
her that she and a number of other
members on the Labour benches have been
saying today in praising the membership
of the European Union effectively
suggesting that what we should be doing
is setting aside the vote of the British
people and remaining in the European
Union that would not be the right thing
to do we must deliver on the vote of the
bit --is--
Julian Keegan Thank You mr. speaker
outside in the real world there are many
employers and employees who are
depending on all of us to take
responsible steps
what the Prime Minister agree with tech
UK who represents over 1 million jobs in
this country in the fast-growing tech
sector whose state failing to achieve
parliamentary approval on the withdrawal
agreement would disrupt supply chains
hit investment and lead to job losses
with small and medium-sized businesses
being the worst effective yet I say to
my honourable friend when the time comes
for members of this house to vote in the
meaningful vote and to consider the deal
that is before them they will indeed I
believe as I've said earlier need to
recall the duty to deliver on the vote
of the British people but also look very
closely at the implications for the vote
that they are casting it is the jobs and
futures of our constituents that should
be at the forefront of our mind
Sir Edward Davy given how important
immigration was for some leave voters
will the Prime Minister take guarantee
that her immigration white paper will be
published and debated before the
meaningful vote on the deal the issue of
immigration was indeed important for
many people during the vote they wanted
free movement to end what we are
negotiating is an end to free movement
we will publish the immigration white
paper in due course the illness mr.
speaker the Prime Minister has worked
tirelessly over the past 18 months to
achieve this draft agreement the
Waverley constituency which I represent
voted for brexit for many reasons chief
among them was to reverse 40 years of
economic decline in the Prime Minister's
opinion does this Agreement provide the
framework with image to avoid the
economy in coastal towns such as
Lowestoft whether in trade manufacturing
or fishing can I can I say it's my
friend that yes I do believe it does and
crucially of course in terms of fishing
will be out of the CFP and will be able
to work to enhance and
the fortunes of our fishing industry but
also alongside this agreement it's
important to look at what the government
is doing elsewhere for our mock through
a modern industrial strategy for example
to ensure that we are delivering an
economy that works for everyone in all
parts of the UK Tracy Bravin speaker the
Prime Minister has been very determined
to respect the will of the people over
60% of my constituency in Bali and spend
voted to leave believing there'd be
taking back control but this deals back
stop will we be policed by a third party
now today she said it won't be used it
won't be necessary and it will be
temporary but in order for it not to be
used we're going to have to pay who
knows what potentially massive amounts
to the EU to extend the transition
period how it's making my constituents
and the country poorer taking back
control to the Honorable AG the best way
of ensuring that the backstop is not
used is to get the future relationship
the future partnership with the European
Union in place by the 1st of January
2021
mrs. Cheryl Marie mr. speaker well my
right honourable friends please confirm
that other nations will not have access
to anything other than the surplus fish
stocks of British waters that the UK
fleet cannot catch after the 31st of
December 2020 even if the implementation
period is extended it is it is we need
not we have not changed our position
that as of December 2020 the UK should
be an independent coastal state able to
negotiate the issue of access to to its
waters for the following year and
obviously for thereafter Stella Creasy
thank you
the Prime Minister has been on her feet
now for almost two hours she talked
about making difficult choices she also
said that this wasn't a final deal with
the pound set to have its biggest fall
for two years and only seven MPs in two
hours expressing any support for this
deal at all can she tell us what she
expects to change to be able to break
that deadlock the Honourable lady that
what will happen over the next few days
and before before the special European
Council takes place is the final
negotiation in matters relating to the
future relationship to fill out the
details of that future relationship
which will show a future relationship
which will indeed be good for the UK
economy dr. Andrew Morrison a huge
personal respect for the Prime Minister
wherever you stand in this matter can I
urge my right honourable friend to study
evidence given to my select committee
this week by customs experts and in
particular their suggestions around
facilitation and technical ways of
achieving a soft border and one that
does not require a backstop and would
you agree with me that the independent
arbitration panel is bound to find that
the EU does not negotiate the future
arrangement with that in mind it is
likely to be amount of active in bad
faith well indeed and that is the point
of the best endeavours and good faith
references that there are within the
within the document I think crucial and
actually may I first say that this I
think is the first opportunity I have in
this chamber to say a heartfelt thank
you to my honourable friend for the work
he did for the commemorations of
and the centenary of the First World War
I think he can be truly proud of all the
events but he also referenced the issue
of alternative arrangements for the
border in Northern Ireland one of the
changes that have taken place recently
that we got into the protocol into the
joint statement in relation to this
backstop issue is precisely this ability
to look at alternative arrangements
rather than just the binary choice of
the future relationship coming into
place or the backstop coming into place
we've recorded as an option but what is
also important is that if the future
framework is not in place it is possible
to have alternative arrangements for the
border which satisfy the requirement we
all have and the desire we all have to
ensure that there's no hard border
between Northern Ireland and Ireland
Mike gates mr. speaker previous times in
our history with national crises we've
come together on both sides of the house
to resolve those crises the Prime
Minister has made clear that she will
not support extension of article 50 she
said we will be leaving the European
Union regardless in March next year and
she's also ruled out a people's vote
isn't it time she recognised reality and
after all the prevent digis efforts
stood aside for someone else who could
take this country forward in a United
Way
No
Adam Holloway you mr. speaker does the
Prime Minister feel she's listened to
her officials while side lighting have
breakfast secretaries and is she now
disobeying the instruction of my
constituents in Gration I have to say to
my little friend the answer to both of
his questions is no I've worked with I
brexit secretaries and obviously with
officials with the negotiating team
throughout this this process and I
believe the deal that we're proposing
does deliver on the instruction of the
British people dr. Lisa Cameron as a
psychologist it's clear to me today that
the Prime Minister is in denial
pragmatically agreed this deal has been
it doesn't command a majority in this
house if she believes in her deal and
she wants to give back control will she
puts it to the people the answer I've
given earlier on that question stuff it
done millions of people up and down this
country and tens of thousands of
hundreds of thousands of businesses want
this house to get on with it could I say
to my right humble friend as she looks
to develop the future framework I
recognise that we will remain within the
EU procurement rules during the course
of the implementation period the future
framework protocol refers to mutual
opportunities to go beyond the WTO
government procurement agreement could
she give some indications of the house
to whether that will include taking back
control of our own procurement in this
country yes we're developing a framework
for M procurement arrangements
rachael maskel mr. speaker
in the light that no deal will be a
disaster for our nation and in the high
probability that this deal will not be
passed by this house well the prime
minister make it her first step to
extend article 50 to ensure that we
don't fall off a cliff edge no the
government has made clear that we will
not be extending article 50 margin
vicar's nice to speak the draft
agreement states that under no
circumstances may the United Kingdom
apply to its customs territory a customs
tariff which is lower than the common
customs tariff for any good or in part
import from the third country would my
right honourable friend agree that that
is a severe limitation on our
sovereignty and will limit the
opportunities that brexit offers can I
say to my honourable friend that what he
is talking about is the circumstances in
which the backstop and the uk-wide UK
why customs territory has come into
place as I've said earlier that is not a
situation that either side wants to see
happen and even in the circumstances
where the future relationship is not in
place at the end of December 2020 it is
not necessary necessarily the case that
that backstop would come into place
if we look at the future relationship he
will see that there is a specific
reference to the independent trade
policy for the United Kingdom and that
is precisely what we are working to
ensure that we are able to do those
trade polit the trade deals around the
rest of the world and that was one of
the questions we looked at when we put
forward our proposals for the free trade
area with the European Union and we have
gone forward confident that we will be
able to do free trade deals around the
rest of the world Chris Brian I agree
with the Prime Minister that there are
no enemies of the people
in this house there are no traitors
whatever the national newspapers may
have said last year and every single
member will make their own judgement
according to their conscience as to what
is in the best interests of the country
but I think the Honourable member for
railey was right earlier there isn't a
majority
what the Prime Minister is proposing in
this house there is a matter of time now
time is of the essence hundreds of sis
whichever we go after this that have to
be taken lots of legislation that has to
be in place unless is gonna be chaos
would it not make sense now before she
goes to the European Council to have a
vote in this house if she wins she's got
the support of Parliament if she loses
then we have to take another tack we
will have a vote in this house we will
have a vote on this house in this house
on the final deal that is negotiated
with the European Union Council as I
said although we have the outline
political declaration moment we will be
filling that in with further detail
which will be available to members when
they come to that vote Bob Neil give mr.
speaker the Prime Minister and I know
that politics ultimate is about the art
with a possible and that's why I support
her deal and that's why the City
Corporation and all the representatives
of the financial service industry have
supported it not least because it
creates in their words the transition
which is a vital to take forward to
complex issues and in relation to our
future relationships in that area so she
agree that anyone who seeks to that's
what this deal shall weigh very
carefully indeed the impact not just
upon that key economic area but upon the
rest of our economy as well say to my
friend that he's absolutely right I
think when people come to look at their
decision in relation to this deal it
will be important for individual members
of this house to weigh very carefully a
number of factors and the impact of
their decision not only on our financial
services sector but on the economy will
more widely will be one of those Ruth
Smith much mr. speaker my constituency
vote should leave and I promised we
would fight for the best possible brexit
deal for them one that will protect
industry this isn't it
given ceramics is mentioned just once in
the 585 page deal
can we trust the Prime Minister's to
deliver a deal that will benefit my
constituents protect jobs and return
sovereignty the deal that we have agreed
and particularly obviously the future
relationship that we are working on to
fill out the detail of is precisely one
that will be good for manufacturing
industry across the United Kingdom Maggi
through the big issues that my
constituents have voted on the
referendum influenced their votes
well my right friend confirm that
leaving the EU on the terms proposed
will allow us to finally fully control
our borders again yeah yes I'm happy to
give that confirmation to my honourable
friend free movement will end and that
is one of the key elements I believe of
the vote of the referendum that we need
to ensure that we deliver from British
people Kevin Brennan mr. speaker the
analogy for the backstop is an insurance
policy anyone buying an insurance policy
would want to know what the excess is on
that policy is she seriously suggesting
we should sign up for an insurance
policy where we don't know how much the
excess will cost and we also can't leave
that insurance policy without the
agreement of the other party
I say to the Honourable gentleman the
one of the elements of the backstop and
this is where in deciding should we be
in that circumstance whether the
backstop or the extension to the
implementation period would be
preferable one of the elements is that
in the backstop there is no financial
obligation
Rachel McLane when they voted to leave
or remain it was a binary choice on that
on that paper
therefore by that logic is is absolutely
impossible for everybody to get what
they want
certainly compromises are necessary in
the national interest has said so
therefore will she assured us today that
she will exert every effort to outline
of benefits of a future trade deal that
would be in the national interest and
the project protect jobs and the economy
yes I'm happy to give that reassurance
to my honourable friend she's absolutely
right the nature of this negotiation is
that both sides make compromises that is
what happens when two sides come
together to negotiate arrangements such
as such as this but I'm I'm very happy
to assure her that we will make clear
the benefits of the future trade
relationship and the future trade deals
we'll do around the rest of the world
Alistair Carmichael response of the
Scottish fisherman's Federation says and
I quote we have asked the prime minister
for assurances that the establishment of
a new fisheries agreement does not imply
the EU vessels will be guaranteed
continued access to our waters in return
for favorable trade theorems can the
Prime Minister give the Federation Latta
students and if she can can she explain
why it's not in the draft deal gentlemen
but we have made clear in the in the
draft deal in relation to fishing
opportunities that sorry in the outline
political declaration that the United
Kingdom will be an independent coastal
state and that we will be ensuring the
we take control of our waters it will be
the United Kingdom that will be
negotiating access to United Kingdom
waters
James Cartledge given that there is
clearly unease about the non unilateral
ability we have to leave the backstop
surely we have to discuss what credible
circumstances could arise where we would
wish to leave it and the EU would not
wish us to leave does she agree me the
only real scenario I could see is where
we had entered into trade talks with
another country where for example we
were discussing lower standards does she
agree that's highly unlikely would not
be supported by the public and that
therefore although it is not impossible
it is remote that we would be in that
circumstance can I say to my little
friend I absolutely agreed that it was
highly unlikely we'll be in that
circumstance
he's right first of all that we will not
be wanting to lower our standards in any
decisions we take in relation to trade
deals but also act that the backstop is
actually an uncomfortable place for the
European Union they believe that the
backstop actually has advantages for
businesses in the United Kingdom
particularly businesses in Northern
Ireland these are advantages they will
not want to see continuing they have an
interest in this being temporary should
we be in that in that position just as
we do Sami Wilson the northern protocols
make it quite clear that Northern
Ireland will stay under EU single market
law and will also be economically
separated from the rest of the United
Kingdom article 7 19 and 12 show that
first of all even if the EU Ally the UK
to leave a single market dwelling iron
will still stay under single market
arrangements and any border down the
Irish Sea will be subject to the
willingness of the EU to allow that to
be avoided I can't the Prime Minister
then tell us why she can give an
assurance that Northern Ireland's not
coming constitutionally separated from
the native Kingdom and he cannot weakly
stop the earth from GB or is this not a
case of Northern Ireland's being
predominantly
and not been an object surrender to me
have no it is not the case I have
throughout this throughout this
discussion throughout these negotiations
the interests of Northern Ireland have
been one of the key issues that we have
been putting at the forefront of our
mind because of the particular
geographical circumstances of Northern
Ireland and its land border with Ireland
I say the Honourable gentleman Northern
Ireland will leave the single market
with the whole of the United Kingdom
there will be specific regulatory
alignment which I recognize is
uncomfortable I recognize that it will
be in that portion of the single
marketer key which in it relates to
matters that ensure that a frictionless
border can take place between Ireland
and between Ireland and Northern Ireland
that as he will know there are already
some regulatory differences between
Great Britain and Northern Ireland there
is a question in the future that I know
has raised a concern as to whether there
will be regulatory divergence between
Great Britain and Northern Ireland we it
is possible for us and we will make you
know natural commitments to Northern
Ireland in relation to that issue of
because we're talking about a temporary
period of no regulatory divergence the
checks and controls actually relate to
the degree of regulatory divergence so
if there is no regulatory divergence
then obviously that has an impact on
reducing the necessity for any checks
and controls and crucially we also
wanted to make sure the EU wanted to say
that they would determine whether a good
that was pretty well developed or was
produced in Birmingham could be sold in
Belfast we were very clear the EU could
not determine that in the future it will
be the UK government that makes those
determinations as I stand here I think
hard about what this means for my
constituents many of you voted
passionately to leave but many others
who are worried about the impact of
leaving on their livelihoods can I thank
my right honourable friend for all the
work she's doing to reconcile those two
positions in a workable that brexit as a
Kent MP have a particular interest in
avoiding delays at the border at Dover
so we don't get gridlock in Kent could
my writer of friends say more about the
progress made in the future relationship
plans where our trade in goods I first
will say to my honourable friend that I
thank her for the comment that she made
and the recognition that of course by
definition in looking at these issues
there will be compromised
there are people who voted obviously on
both sides of this argument when the
brexit vote came I think the
overwhelming through the British people
now is to see the government getting on
and delivering brexit for the British
people and she asked specifically about
goods we have expressly within the
outline political declaration and we
will be fleshing this out in the future
framework full of future framework
document put at a key a key element at
the forefront of our thinking is the
need to ensure that we can have that
continuing good trading relationship
with that good transfer that seamless
transfer of goods across borders Gareth
snell I've been very clear the my
constituents voted to leave the European
Union the only way that we can do that
smoothly is leaving with a deal however
it is clear from the speeches that we
made in this house today that the Prime
Minister steel does not have a majority
she has also rolled out article 50 and
she has also said that she would not
support a second referendum and I do not
believe a majority exists for that in
this place anyway
but I hope like me the Prime Minister
realizes that no deal would be a
catastrophe so could I ask her to
outline her contingency between this
deal failing and preventing a No Deal
breaks on the 29th of March the the
decision about this deal will be one
that will come before this house in the
meaningful vote and every member will
have the opportunity to exercise their
vote according to their conscience and
according to the need to deliver for the
British people consideration of the
impact that the decision may take will
have on the futures of their
constituents Simon Hall
I hope my right honourable friend would
agree with me that we would be extreme
unwise to sacrifice the good on the
altar of theological perfection and if
she does agree with me with that
principled point can't you tell me if
this is a good deal for the farmers and
food producers not just of my
constituency of North Dorset but for the
country as a whole I will say to my
honourable friend that I think it is
important that in pro in approaching
this issue of the deal and honourable
members when they look when they come to
the meaningful vote should look at this
in questions of the realities of the the
impact and the practicalities of the
deal that we have put put before will
put before this house he asked
specifically about farmers in his
constituency of North Dorset and
elsewhere I can reassure him that I
think in two sentences this delivers for
them first of all of course we will be
able to come out of the Common
Agricultural Policy and develop our own
policy for agriculture that does meet
the needs of farmers across the United
Kingdom and secondly of the it when we
talk about the frictionless border of
course people often talk about
manufactured goods but fresh produce
going across the those borders is also
equally important Tahlia antoniak see
you mr. speaker the local schaefler
plant closed in two hundred jobs eight
hundred virgin media job losses since
the 2016 referendum there have been more
job losses than jobs created it is
increasingly obvious that my
constituents and constituents in Wales
are worse off and shouldn't this
government respect the future well-being
of the people by asking for a people's
vote my answer I've answered the
question in relation to the people's
vote on a number of occasions on your
fro referred the Honourable lady to
answer I had given previously on that I
had to say to her we the employment
figures that we saw earlier this week
showed that we now see him employment at
a record high in this country in recent
years including since the referendum
jobs have been created in this country
Lee Rowley
I have the huge amount of respect for my
local friends and it gives me no
happiness to say this but the thing I've
heard in the last two hours suggests
that this is anything other than a bad
deal
when will my own friend realize that in
places like Northeast our be sure this
is not the deal that they voted for that
they want or that they will accept my
honourable friend in response to his
question I believe and obviously he will
have an understanding of the reasons
behind the vote for his individual
constituents in northeast Derbyshire I
think if we look across his constituency
and others some of the key issues that
people wanted to see from leaving the
European Union were an end to free
movement we will deliver an end to free
movement I think they wanted to see an
end to the jurisdiction of the European
Court of Justice we will deliver that as
well we will no longer be sending vast
amounts of money to the European Union
every year we will come out of policies
that have been of concern for a long
time in this country the Common
Agricultural Policy and the Common
Fisheries Policy and we will be ensuring
that as I say we have we have delivered
on what I believe the key elements of
the vote that people took while we do
that I think it's also right that we
think of people's jobs in Northeast Asia
and elsewhere and that's why I think it
is important that we look for a good
trade in relationship with the European
Union in the future quality is based on
a free trade area that enables
manufacturing to continue to operate as
it has as it can do today Paula Sheriff
mr. speaker to see Prime Minister now
accept that she inadvertently misled the
nation during her now infamous Lancaster
House speech which appear to offer a
utopian vision of vision of brexit
possibly designed to appeal as both
wings of her divided party that simply
cannot and never could be delivered here
here
say to the honorable lady that all the
speeches I have made and the decisions
that the government has taken are
compatible with the Lancaster House
speech well the Lancaster House speech
at its core set out was that in the new
relationship with the European Union we
had to have a new balance of rights and
obligations and that is exactly what we
are delivering David Duke it
constituents of my constituents of my
constituents a man from Bakken and I
welcome Mary normal friends repeated and
consistent commitment that we will be
leaving the CFP of course being out of
the EU means we're out of the CFP in the
same way that bein in the EU which is
the policy of the Scottish Nationalist
Party and others means being in the CFP
you know it does will she also commit
that unfettered access to UK waters by
EU fishing vessels out with our ability
to control as an independent coastal
state will not be part of any future
trade agreement of the EU can I say to
my little friend that we are very clear
that we will be an independent coastal
state there have been attempts to link
fisheries and link access to fishing
waters to the trade aspect of this
negotiation we have been very clear that
we will not accept that that we want
will be an independent coastal state so
that it is the United Kingdom
determining access to UK waters
uncertainty about our future trading
relationships with the EU is undermining
British business and having a chilling
effect on our economic growth there is
absolutely nothing in this so-called
deal which actually dispels or resolves
the issues which are making for this
will the Prime Minister recognize that
instead of negotiating
the economic kamikaze tendency on our
own party
she needs to reach out to this side of
the house build a consensus or take the
issue again to the public what the
decision the decision that was taken
yesterday actually gives that certainty
to business which is why business have
been welcoming that deal so we hear
Richard Walker from Iceland
it delivers a clear path ahead that
business so desperately needs we see
from the FSB I quoted earlier this
brings with it some certainty that our
small businesses have craved and there
are other quotes from business business
have welcomed the fact that we have
recognized the needs of manufacturing
industry in putting forward our
proposals for the future relationship
Simon Clark
Mr Speaker I commend the premise what
she has said to members opposite anody
that the hand from our own side who have
called for a politicians vote on the
issue of the second referendum it simply
would not be appropriate at this time
however it must be said that her words
that no deal is better than a bad deal
are the words which govern my position
today I cannot support that deal does
she appreciate that for many of us she
has placed as this an impossible
position what our loyalty to her and to
our party is set against our loyalty to
our constituents so gentle I rep I fully
recognize the the issue that we are
dealing with raises some difficult
decisions for individual members of this
house and the choices before members of
this house are not easy and I absolutely
recognize that and as I said obviously
we will when the final deal is brought
back to this house individual members
will want to look at the details of that
and consider obviously at the forefront
the interests of their constituents the
interests of this country as a whole as
I say I recognize that this is not an
easy decision for people to take I
believe that what we have negotiated is
in the best interest of our country over
we will be filling out more details of
that before the matter comes before the
house and I hope members of the house
will be able to look at that fuller
detail and can consider the various
issues that they have to do so when they
do that and but that in no way says that
this will be an easy choice and I fully
recognize that Karen Rowley I voted
remain but I represent a leave
constituency I try really hard to
represent everybody in Lincoln not just
the ones that shout the loudest and I
get I truly get an evenly split mailbox
on this I genuinely do but I feel that
this deal doesn't meet the aspirations
and hopes of either side it fails to
protect jobs in the economy and it
creates a border down the Irish Sea I
would just say if the Prime Minister
will not listen to the Labour benches
will she not look at the faces of her
own side and listen to their words and
actually recognize this is a really bad
deal this deal does not create a border
on the Irish Sea and this deal does take
the future relationship the outline
political declaration does take the
interests of people's jobs into account
in ensuring that we are negotiating a
free trade area that will enable that
good trade relationship to keep -
maintained with the European Union which
enables job to be not just maintained
here in the UK but created here in okay
Colin Clark is the prime minister clear
how committed her loyal Scottish
Conservative colleagues are to fishing
and the Union yes I'm I'm very clear and
indeed I would say to my honourable
friend that I think he he and our
Scottish colleagues on the conservative
benches are an admirable contrast to the
SNP were committed to neither fishy
nor the Union Pete we sharped and the
last few months the Prime Minister has
lost the better quarter of a capital
with more resignations to follow as
we've seen dead on arrival he was being
trashed by large sections of a back
bench and there are partly letters
waiting the way to the Honourable member
for acting and seal
how many more indignities was a prime
minister had to endure before she
considers her position my position is
that I have only one duty and that is to
deliver for the British people in the
national interest Prime Minister will be
aware that hartfordshire is fortunate
enough to have some major businesses in
Farmer in industries in the aerospace
industry working to the motor industry
and so on and they rely on having short
times for the delivery of parts just in
time our arrangements of that sort they
have integrated manufacture across
Europe can the Prime Minister say if she
feels that this agreement that she has
put before us is going to be in the best
interests of businesses like that and
all the jobs in hartfordshire which rely
on them my friend that I do believe that
is the case the future relationship in
developing this future relationship with
European Union we have indeed been
considering as one of the key issues the
need to ensure that trade across the
borders those just-in-time supply chains
can continue because many jobs in
constituencies around the country depend
on that so I can give my right
honourable friend that assurance I
visited a business in Croydon recently
and they are currently looking at
warehouses just outside Amsterdam to
move their business to because they
think that the direction of travel that
this government has taken on brexit will
not work for them now it's clear the
Prime Minister is not going to get a
vote in this house for this
she has ruled out extending article 50
she's ruled out a general election she's
ruled out a people's vote she's ruled
out No Deal as well so can I ask the
prime minister to categorically state
for the sake of the businesses in
Croydon that are waiting right now to
know what is going to happen in the
future what will she do if she loses the
votes in Parliament if she is concerned
about the businesses in Croydon she
should look carefully at the future
relationship that we're developing with
the European Union we will fill out
permit further details in relation to
that but that future relationship will
deliver for the businesses in Croydon
will deliver on the issues that they
have expressed concerns about and will
deliver in a way that ensures jobs can
be kept in her constituency this is
David Troodon a friend on securing this
deal and say that there's much in here
that will please my constituents who
voted very strongly to come out
including taking control of our borders
in any of the free movement of labour
but may I save the Prime Minister I
think her task in bringing this to the
house for a meaningful vote will be much
helped if she can flesh out the future
relationship this is absolutely Chris
Wright and for those of her friends in
Europe who are listening to this debate
if they can come to her aid and make it
clear that they really do want a future
relationship secured before the back
storm comes into place she has the real
chance of carrying this house Frank
thank my humble friend for his comments
and I can give him the reassurance that
I will be filling out the detail we will
be in the negotiations in the coming
days filling out the detail of that
future framework so that when the house
comes to take that meaningful vote they
will have be able to have a better
understanding of the nature of the
future relationship which is one as I
say that I believe will be able to
deliver for industry across the across
the country for agriculture for fishing
and indeed deliver on our security via
Hobhouse
does she accept that the fracturing of
her own party demonstrate that the Seb
ting and a half million people who voted
leave in 2016 were not United in what
brexit means for them and therefore her
claim of delivering on the majority vote
of the British people is incorrect the
majority vote of the British people was
to deliver the was to leave the European
Union and that's what we will deliver
Kevin Foster Thank You mr. speaker I
believe those who voted leaving to obey
did Stokes and receive global trade in
Britain which we epitomized by us
joining the comprehensive and
progressive agreement for trans-pacific
partnership which includes some more
oldest allies including the very what
the one which gifted that very
despatch-box
which could reassure me the deal she's
proposing will facilitate British
membership of that agreement friend that
reassurance we specifically looked when
we were looking at this this proposal as
to whether it would be possible to join
the CPB TPP and I can give him the
assurance that it would and not only
that it would be possible for us to join
it but also that there are members of
the CP TPP who are keen for us to join
it such as Japan and Australia
Vernon Coker mr. speaker given the fact
that it's obviously clear from the
contributions today and the questions to
the prime minister that there is not a
parliamentary majority for the deal that
she's bringing forward today what is the
plan that the Prime Minister has got
just a wait for the lot vote to be lost
and then panic the British people
deserve better than that the Prime
Minister has integrity she has not got
the confidence of this house to put this
deal through and there needs to be
alternatives brought before us and the
British people
the right honorable gentleman we will
negotiate the remaining details of this
deal and there will be obviously the EU
Council on the 25th of November that
will then be brought back to this house
information will be made available to
members members of this house which is
at that point that members of this house
will determine whether they wish to
support the deal might would with which
part of the financial settlement under
the proposed withdrawal agreement would
be payable during the implement
implementation period and during any
backstop financial settlement has a
trajectory in terms of terms of payment
some of which would be in fact beyond
the periods that my honourable friend
has referred to there is no specific
financial obligation in relation to the
backstop should that backstop come into
play
Patrick Grady is so confident of the
merits of this deal is she not slightly
concerned when she goes to Europe other
member states will look after enviously
and what to leave the European Union on
several terms or does it not in fact
give ya2 the truth that say the best
possible relationship by definition with
the European Union is the one that my
constituents the people across Scotland
for which is to remain in the European
[Music]
I'm tempted to refer the Honourable
gentleman to answers I gave earlier on
this question we had a vote the overall
vote was that we should leave the
European Union and that's what we will
deliver Thank You mr. speaker on all
important political decisions not only
do I listen to my constituents and the
businesses that employ my constituents
but I also ask myself the question is
this in the long-term interests of my
children I have a great deal of respect
for the Prime Minister she's a dedicated
public servant so can I ask her with all
sincerity given all the viable options
available is this deal in the best
interest of my children and I I say to
my honourable friend that I genuinely
believe this deal is in the national
interest
that means that is in the best interests
of people up and down the United Kingdom
of whatever age they are including those
who were children today what I want to
do is to ensure that as we leave the
European Union we are able to build that
brighter future both with a good trade
relationship with the EU afternoon this
is sky news live from Westminster at
1:00 p.m. and the Prime Minister Theresa
May has been defending her brexit
agreement plans to MPs in Parliament
after a rave of resignations she's been
in the Commons now for two and a half
hours this session was originally shown
to last three hours as she answers
questions from MPs but her day did not
start well this morning shalosh vara a
junior minister quit as Minister in the
Northern Ireland office saying mrs.
Mayer's agreement leaves the UK in a
halfway house and then in a huge blow to
the prime minister Dominic Raab resigned
as Brickton secretary saying the Prime
Minister's plan threatens the integrity
of the United Kingdom he was followed by
estimate veishea stood down as Work and
Pensions secretary saying the brexit
deal does not honor the result of the
referendum a number of other ministers
including sweller brotherman quit as a
junior brexit Minister calling the
backstop a betrayal and anne-marie
Trevelyan resigned as an aide in the
Department of Education saying she can't
support mrs. Mays deal
the latest resignation is Ronald Juwanna
he has quit as parliamentary private
secretary the most junior sort of
minister to the Ministry of Justice
saying the deal does not deliver on
personal integrity and tick them at the
want so high as Kenna payments are
confirmed has she received any
correspondence conforming their
resignations or intentions to do so
I'm sorry I thought the honorable
gentleman was asking me effectively
whether any members of the cabinet or
ministers had resigned and I think he
will see from the public information
that there have been some faisal rashid
mr. speaker after two years of
insecurity and uncertainty the Prime
Minister is proposing an outline deal
which is a real backwards step from the
position the UK is now councils up and
down the country like mine in Warrington
are urging MPs to ask from a people's
Ward so they have a say on whether to be
worse off does the Prime Minister agree
with me that it is in the national
interest now to go back to the people of
this country and also if Parliament
won't down this deal will she give
British people a voice we gave the
British people a voice we gave them the
opportunity to choose between leaving
and remaining in the European Union they
chose to leave and that's what will
deliver mr. Richard bacon mr. speaker
mr. speaker when we become an
independent coastal state again which I
very much look forward to of course our
fishing waters will need protecting will
the Prime Minister consider
commissioning a new fleet of very fast
naval vessels to chase down and capture
any vessels that come into our waters to
fish uninvited thus protecting fishing
and our rights to fishing in Scotland
and right down the east coast to East
Anglia including my neighbours
constituency of Lowestoft - my
honourable friend I'm not sure whether
his question was more intended to be a
support for the fishing industry or a
bid for the Ministry of Defence spending
review we will be ensuring that we can
operate as an independent coastal state
and protect the interests of our fishing
industry
BAM boss Chadha lumbus many people think
that this is a bad deal has lip support
in the house has got ready to chance of
passing so come on sir Prime Minister -
tell me what safeguards there aren't for
you came EU citizens in the event of a
No Deal Brixton being very clear that an
event of a No Deal brexit European Union
citizens who are living here in the
United Kingdom will have their rights
protected Stuart welcome McDonald when
is the next general election 2022
[Applause]
Tamm Manjeet Singh deci thank you very
much mr. speaker this government's
budget approach to Brazil is the worst
of both worlds for both leave and
remains does the Prime Minister not
agree that whilst we have given the
government two years to make a complete
dog's breakfast or brigs it negotiations
and still not be a position to command a
majority in this house
it is now high time to end this Sharad
to waste no further time and to have a
meaningful vote and for us to take back
control in this house there will be a
meaningful vote there will be a
meaningful vote on the final deal as is
as if as it as it is agreed with the
European Union Jim Shannon Speaker I
stand here as a figure with a heavy
heart and get sadness and does the Prime
Minister or will the Prime Minister
recollect about legal story of Jacob and
Esau where I saw saw those birth rate
for a bowl of hot ice does the Prime
Minister see the similarity this year
they're coming to see my children and
grandchildren's mercy and constituents
rate to be British and for a despicable
and surely did I should be kept and said
before our adversaries the cheater
claims his price what need of further
lies we are the sacrifice Prime Minister
we will not be your sacrifice and will
not give two more agree to give the
backstop control to the EU or to the
Republic Ireland over Northern Ireland
never honourable gentlemen I very much
respect
I respect the honourable gentleman and I
respect the concerns that he has showed
in relation to this issue of the
backstop we are not but I while
respecting him
I do reject the description that he has
given of what is being done in relation
to this deal as I've said earlier there
is it is clear that it is necessary to
have a withdrawal agreement and in that
withdrawal agreement to have this
insurance policy there are various ways
in which that insurance policy can be
exercised and it is my
certainly firm hope and my intention
everything that we work and do to ensure
that the backstop does not need to be
put into practice
Chris Stephens the Prime Minister will
be aware there were 27 million UK
citizens without who hold a European
health insurance card so can I ask an
after December 2020 what would be the
status of the the European health
insurance card as applies to UK citizens
well it'd be redundant after January
2021 can I say to honourable gentlemen I
will perhaps write to him with specifics
on the health because issue that is an
issue that has been negotiated in
relation to the period to December 2020
I think the the question of the any
reciprocal rights in relation to health
care is a matter that is still to be
negotiated for the future relationship
but I will write to him with more detail
Chris Elmore the Prime Minister has been
asked time and time again this question
but I'll try again she is heared across
the house there is no support for her
deal she will not call a general
election
she won't support a people's vote she
won't extend article 50 and her threat
is her Deal or No Deal
so can she confirm that if the house
doesn't support her deal she will push
us off the No Deal cliff edge as I have
said in response to others when the
house comes to look at this deal it will
be for every member of this house to
consider not only the duty to the duty
to ensure that we deliver on the vote of
the British people but also to consider
the long-term interests of their
constituents
Kirsti Blackman yes mr. speaker the
Prime Minister hasn't explained what in
the national interest actually means so
can't you tell us compared to remaining
in the EU how many extra jobs she
believes will be created
how much faster our GDP will grow and
how much better off will each family be
honourable lady just to give her an
example of one of the issues that she
raised if she looked at that looked at
the report that the OPR produced at the
time of the budget
well well understanding that we were
leaving the European Union they said
that over the next few years 800,000
more jobs will be created
ian's see Lucas speaker on Northern
Ireland in the protocol paragraph four
of the of the agreement contains the
further the following extraordinary
statement the partners should use their
best endeavours to seek to facilitate
trade between Great Britain and Northern
Ireland what assurance does that give to
this house about the integrity of the
United Kingdom in working and are very
clear in the issues that we have
developed that there will continue to be
that trade between Northern Ireland and
Great Britain I've made I responded a
little earlier to another honourable
member of the House in relation to the
impact of any regulatory requirements
that there are as a result of the UK EU
wide customs territory I also was clear
about the changes that we have brought
about in terms of approvals for example
for the ability of companies to be able
to sell and to have that business across
the across between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland it was one of the
commitments we gave in December and its
commitment that continues alive Lewis
mr. speaker I'm sure the irony has not
been missed on the Prime Minister that
it's exactly 80 years ago that another
conservative Prime Minister came back
from Europe waving a piece of paper and
claiming success I believe the exact
words were peace in our time and it was
Neville Chamberlain
given that there is no peace on the
benches opposite given that you do not
command it not command the support of
this house can the Prime Minister tell
us what the options are a general
election or a people's vote or a hard
brexit cliff edge the honorable
gentlemen have heard the answer that I
have given to other members of this
house when the deal is brought back from
the European Council to this house it
will be up to individual members of this
Parliament - of this house to determine
whether they believe that is a deal that
they can support in the interests of
their constituents and in the national
interest or not Matt Weston speaker
following this debate the odds are that
the government will be forced into a
u-turn on this other property namely the
fudge over brexit terms given the
meaningful vote is likely to fail would
it not now be prudent for the prime
minister to ask the EU for an extension
to article 50 and offer the public a
second vote
come on to answers I've given earlier to
both of those questions Albin promised
that we all understand the importance of
the Belfast agreements but these special
arrangements for one part of the United
Kingdom that is Northern Ireland will
have an impact on the rest of the United
Kingdom including seaports on the
western seaboard because it will create
that the fact though aligned across the
Irish Sea so can I ask her because she
has managed one thing today mr. speaker
and that's to unite the DUP my party and
sections of her own party on this issue
so can I ask her to go back to Brussels
this isn't a final agreement look at
this again let's have fairness and unity
in the United Kingdom say to the
honourable gentleman that I think he's
referring to the circumstances of if the
back stop was operated of course the
broader the border issues between the
way the border would operate between
Northern Ireland Ireland would be
different from the way the border would
operate between Great Britain and the
rest of the European Union that's
exactly that's exactly one of the
one of the issues that will be
considered should there be at the point
of having to determine whether the best
option was the backstop or indeed the
implementation period because of if it
was an extension of the implementation
period then of course the frictionless
border with the rest of the EU would
continue as it is today
well Esther CERN the prime minister says
that it is a choice between her botched
option or No Deal it's crystal clear to
everyone there is no support in this
house majority support in this house for
either of those options and it's also
clear that the half-hearted preparation
for No Deal means she knows that's not a
realistic choice so when is she going to
admit that she needs to allow Parliament
to come up with alternatives and she
better do this sooner rather than later
honourable gentlemen that we are making
clear preparations for No Deal we have
continued to make those preparations we
have stepped we step to those
preparations up this summer Parliament
will have an opportunity to vote on the
deal in the meaningful vote pull
thoroughly Thank You mr. speaker right
at the answer today the right honourable
learn at member for Russian if quite
rightly stressed the importance of
freedom of goods but services are also a
vital part of our economy at which we
are very good so could the Prime
Minister explain what benefits her
approach give to the services sector
that it doesn't already enjoy and
importantly what influence would it give
in the future after transition on the
future development of the single market
including the digital single market the
old gentlemen will know once we've
leaved the European Union we will not be
participating in decisions that the
European Union takes in relation to its
its particular market I think it is
important because services are so
important to the UK economy the the
flexibility that is set out in the
outline political declaration is
available to services or financial
services and others this is a key area
for the United Kingdom and it's a key
area in which I expect that we will be
able to develop good trip a good
partnerships and good relationship
it's not just with the European Union
but with other parts of the world as
well to the interests of his
constituents and others across this
country Peter Grant mr. speaker the
claim Minister finally admitted last
night that a lot too but three possible
outcomes from previous time to snow yet
she still insists that Parliament will
all live alike bainitic choice between
two of them will be denied the right to
vote on only one of the three options as
any chance of commanding majority
support well bill demott denied the
right to vote on the one that majority
of MPs no believe is in the best
interests of our constituents and my
first etched imagination does that
constitute a meaningful wall and
parallel universe can it be described as
the tunnelling control to Parliament the
meaningful vote will be a meant an
amendable motion but as I have said
previously I think if you went and asked
most members of the public if the
government brings a deal back from
Brussels what do you expect Parliament
to vote on I think they would expect
Parliament to be able to have a vote on
that deal Clive effort Thank You mr.
speaker those promises got to accept
responsibility for the position she's
put herself in it was she who thought it
was a good idea to make the member for
Oxbridge her foreign secretary she's
appointed to arch brexit errs has the
brexit secretaries these people were
always going to lay her low and desert
her so she's now left with no majority
for her position in the house so surely
she has to hold a vote in this house to
give him indicative position of the
House of Commons on this deal before she
goes to a summit at the end of this
month so she can honestly represent the
views of this house on the deal that she
has negotiated houses will be able to
take a vote on the final deal that is
negotiated with the European Council
that is what we have committed to this
house and that is what will happen
Neil grey speaker the people of Scotland
voted by a wide margin to remain within
the EU and ever since that point the
Democratic wishes of the people of
Scotland have been disrespected as have
the wishes of the democratically elected
Scottish Parliament and the Scottish
Government who put forward compromise
possessions to the government a UK
government on a break
but can she confirmed that yesterday the
disrespect to the people of Scotland was
extended threefold
firstly in terms of providing a
differential deal to Northern Ireland
secondly in terms of providing briefings
to the government of Gibraltar before
the Scottish Government and thirdly as
was pointed out on Radio Scotland this
morning by the Honourable member from
West Aberdeen shunkan Cardin that the
government the conservative members from
Scotland were briefed in the text of the
withdrawal agreement before the Scottish
government is that the case the
Honourable gentleman that he he talks
about respecting the positions that have
been taken throughout this we have
respected the fact that we are
negotiating on behalf of the whole of
the United Kingdom and in the interests
of the whole of the United Kingdom and
we have continued to do that and will
continue to do that and Scotland of
course is part of the United Kingdom
Martin Whitfield read for mr. speaker
and also tyre and indulgence earlier
today I'd like to ask the Prime Minister
why is no brexit a risk to the United
Kingdom and my constituency the slogan
the people of this country the people of
this country voted to leave the European
Union I believe it is in the their
interests and in the duty of this
Parliament to deliver it what I said
what I said was a risk of no brexit at
all a taking case in his number of
members across this house from those
opposition benches that said that they
would prefer to keep us in the European
Union I disagree the British people
voted to leave and we will leave Alex
Norris Speaker my primary concern
through this process has been jobs in my
community and nobody knows more about
negotiating for jobs and our nation's
trade unions that represent millions and
millions of working people since this
deals been struck has the Prime Minister
spoken to our unions or their
representatives and if not what day will
she do so
and I assure the honorable gentleman
that the interests of trade unions and
the interests of businesses have been
taken into account in the in the work
that has been done there has been
interaction with trade unions that there
is from my great honorable friend the
secretary state for business energy and
industrial strategy annalisa Dodds very
specific question and I would like a
specific answer the statement of intent
for the EU settlement scheme said those
applying will not be required to show
that they meet all the requirements of
current free movement rules that's been
contradicted by the latest set of
immigration regulations from my reading
this agreement is ambiguous on that
point so can she indicate whether as she
promised it will be possible for people
to get settled status where they can
prove they've been resident and can pass
a criminality check but they might not
be able through no fault of their own to
prove that they've been exercising their
EEA treaty rights I think I heard the
Honourable lady say that the the
regulations were ambiguous and therefore
and but she claimed that that ambiguity
necessarily contradicted what had been
said previously in the interests of
making sure that the Honourable lady
gets his a curative reply as possible I
will write to her on this matter
Darrin James Thank You mr. speaker there
are a number of simple truths amongst
the political noise firstly for eggs it
is bad for Britain secondly that the
Prime Minister proposal has no majority
in this house and thirdly that on the
future relationship the thing that all
of my constituents wish to know about
regardless of their view on Briggs it is
a seven-page wish list and nothing else
the prime minister said today that
she'll bring further details to the
house but can she confirm how long we
will have as a house and Select
Committee's and as constituency MPs in
conversation with our constituents to
fully understand the consequences of her
future proposal but in the UK and the EU
we will be ensuring that Parliament
before it takes the meaningful vote is
able to see both of what both the future
framework as it is developed in greater
detail than it is at the moment in the
outline political declaration together
with as I've indicated earlier the
various forms of analysis that the
government has committed to Paul Sweeney
Scottish Tory MPs no longer confidence
in our Secretary of State for Scotland
who has been trampled over on fisheries
and on the Irish backstopping couldn't
even turn up today hoping the Prime
Minister
seriously suggests that this deal offers
anything other than undermining the
integrity of the United Kingdom the
integrity and his portrayal of the
position of the Secretary of State for
Scotland is completely wrong the
Secretary of State for Scotland is doing
an excellent job together with my
conservative colleagues Scottish
Conservative colleagues on these benches
in defending the interests of Scotland
and in doing so in a rather better way
than the SNP
Luke Graham thank you very much
inspector mr. speaker just come back on
the Honorable gentleman's comment there
to be very clear the Secretary of State
hasn't had a redline crossed the my
valuable friend and I hope she will
affirm again that we will negotiate
fishing as an independent coastal state
in 2020 and furthermore Scotland has
been respected as an ADIZ being
respected by consulting Scottish MPs in
this house as is appropriate for
pointing that out and I'm clear to
confirm the commitments I gave earlier
about the position of the United Kingdom
as an independent coastal state Brendan
O Hara given the absence of the wesauce
spotted Secretary of State for Scotland
and the last 40 else could the Prime
Minister take this opportunity to
explain to those living in my already
economically fragile of Gailen
constituency exactly why hard deal puts
them at a competitive disadvantage to
the very close neighbors in Northern
Ireland SNP members have on a number of
occasions now referred to the the issue
of Northern Ireland in relation to
Scotland and this deal Northern Ireland
has a particular set of circumstances
that do not owe the honourable gentleman
says oh and we do not know you do not
this is really the height of discourtesy
the promise results during the question
and must be heard she's the questions
just been asked Primus is answering it
and the Honorable Judge Marie's
jabbering away from the secondary
position to know of his benefit or
purpose the Prime Minister was raising a
question of suggestion that actually
Scotland was in the same position as
northern and of course it's not it
doesn't have a land border where the
country that's going to be within the
European Union ruth carried key mr.
speaker the deal this deal is far worse
for our young people than the deal they
currently have with our membership with
the EU this deal has no guarantees on
erasmus on funding for EU students on
their travel and work rights in Europe
on alien research funding worth a
hundred billion euros when the future of
millions of young people are at stake
doesn't she agree that it's time to let
them vote for their future with the
people's vote particularly for those
young people who didn't get a vote last
time because they weren't told there are
references in the in what we have agreed
in relation to some of the matters that
she has that she has set forward but
this is a deal which is about the future
of this country it is about oh she's
holding up the withdrawal agreement that
withdrawal agreement actually is about
always draw from the European Union it
is not about our future relationship the
matter she referred to our about our
future relationship Ian Murray mr.
speaker can the Prime Minister look at
my constituents in the eye and guarantee
that this withdrawal agreement will put
them in a better position in which they
currently enjoy as a member of the
European Union and promised to them that
not one of my constituents will be a
penny worse off as a result of this
Agreement what is going to ensure the
future of the honourable gentleman's
constituents and those of members and
right honourable members across this
house is not the withdrawal agreement
but the future relationship that we did
deliver with the European Union that's
precisely why we have put the element of
the economic partnership as such an
important part of that future
relationship Stuart C MacDonald Thank
You mr. speaker the Prime Minister has
yet to answer a simple but very
important question if he'll do is
rejected what will her government do
next as I said and that said quite a lot
earlier in answering a question there is
the process that will happen with that
to happen is set out quite clearly for
this house but this question your
question is how an individual members of
this house
approach this decision when they come to
make it in the interests of the country
and in the interests of their
constituents and they will need to have
at the forefront of their minds the duty
to deliver on the vote of the British
people to leave the European Union and
the overall national interest of our
country and the interests of their
constituents Anna MAHT Morris mr.
speaker the world is looking on us with
horror and sympathy my constituents in
Cardiff North people up and down Wales
and across the UK worried how to make
ends meet they know right now that
brexit is bad for Britain can the Prime
Minister tell my constituents exactly
how this deal will make them better off
than they are now the Honourable lady
says that she is concerned I've set out
before why I think this deal and the
future partnership we can have with the
European Union and trade deals around
the rest of the world can benefit of our
economy benefit jobs benefit the
Honourable lady's constituents
she says her constituents worry about
how having how to make ends meet it's
precisely why this government is a
government that has continued to
increase the national living wage that
has been put through tax and put through
tax cuts for millions of people in this
country hey Catherine worst Thank You
mr. speaker could the Prime Minister
enlighten the house as to why the member
for sale and antonyms may be meeting
with the Chief Whip at this moment
nothing to do with the statement there's
nothing to do with the statement dr.
Paul Williams thank you thank you mr.
speaker and thank you to the prime
minister for staying to answer
everyone's questions the primary the
prime minister says that we risk no
brexit at all our NHS relies on EU
workers and depends on EU research and
medicines collaboration how is this deal
better for the NHS the no brexit I say
to the honourable gentleman first of all
that the British people voted to leave
the European Union and we have a duty to
deliver on leaving the European Union if
he is if he is concerned about the
future of the National Health Service
and I hope he supports the significant
decision that this government has taken
to make the biggest injection of funding
into our National Health Service in its
history with our multi-year funding
program over 80 billion pounds more
going into the National Health Service
and the 10-year plan that ensures the
sustainability of our NHS into the
future Prime Minister thank you
colleagues think
so
order I'll take the honorable
gentleman's point of order rich material
to what we've been discussing but I do
then wish to proceed thank you to the
business statement point of order mr.
Neil gray mr. speaker on a point of
order it was suggested this morning on
radio Scotland by the Honourable member
from West Aberdeen Sharon King Cardin
and later confirmed apparently by the
member from local and South Persia but
the conservative members of this house
from Scotland will give an advanced
sight of the withdrawal agreement before
other party leaders in this house and
before the democratically elected
devolved administration's now I know my
constituents near in shorts would see
that has been disorderly and
disrespectful but I wonder mr. speaker
whether you could confirm in terms of
the rules of this house whether that was
disorderly and disrespectful
the year here that day nothing to do
with the rules of the house I mean I'm
sorry to disappoint the honourable
gentleman if he thinks there is but it's
nothing to do with the rules of the
house there are judgments to be made in
this matter and opinions will differ as
to the wisdom of particular courses of
action but there's been no breach of
order
I absolutely recognise the irritation or
dissatisfaction of the Honorable
gentleman but that is distinct from any
question of procedural impropriety point
of water is dilute Graham yeah just in
response to the point of order that was
just made I just want to clarify yeah
yeah he can raise a point of order if he
just wants to have a tip for tact with
another honourable member that is not a
proper use of a point of order
he wanted a tit-for-tat no everyone's a
ruling very good point of order mr. Luke
Graham - I would look for your ruling
and advice and clarification on how to
make sure the record is is read
correctly in relation to a point that
was made in the house earlier today
regarding the point that was made by
members on this side of the house by
Scottish Conservatives in looking at
government texts before been released to
other MPs in the previous statement I
had mentioned about the